Start.
It can be.
Yeah.
Okay.
Chris Ryan and I have decided that for my friend Steve Run is easy.
Who just admitted that he lied about working in the September 11th,
uh,
the twin towers during September 11th.
That we're just going to lie all day.
So this podcast is all bullshit.
Everything we say psychologically it,
fuck this.
This is a,
this is a tough one for me cause I really liked Steve.
He's a good friend.
I really liked that guy.
See Him at the comedy store all the time.
I've known him for years.
I really like him and then I see this and I'm just like,
Jesus Christ,
you know what,
what gets me,
it gets me when someone does something like this is I imagine what it would be
like to be them to have told some sort of a crazy line and got stuck telling it
where you're repeating it over and over again and then you just got,
it just becomes like,
it's,
it's locked in.
It's like how do you erase it?
How do you go back and get a lie away?
Especially if you transition from like a regular guy who just bullshits with his
friends to a public figure.
Like I guess this guy got famous at that point.
Right.
So then you've got your lies that all your friends think are true and now you're
doing interviews with the fucking Wall Street Journal or whatever.
And if that comes up,
what do you do?
You stick to your guns or you humiliate yourself,
you know in your private circle.
You know,
cause you got a,
there's that,
well apparently
did humiliate himself in his private circle.
He pulled Ari and up few guys aside years ago and told them that it wasn't true.
No Shit.
Yeah.
Oh that's interesting.
I mean I guess it just been fucking with them forever,
you know.
Good for him.
He's coming out of the closet.
Although he got pulled out of the closet.
I think that you have pulled out by the New York Times.
The New York Times got them.
You know,
they do their research and they found out that he didn't really work for Merrill
Lynch.
You know,
he said he worked for Merrill Lynch for like a year and a half as an account
manager.
Didn't really work with Maryland.
Well,
as you were saying before,
the Mikes.
Why not like what a dumb ass lie.
Oh,
Merrill Lynch Account Manager.
Well how,
let me suck your Dick.
Like who gives a shit?
You don't need to work for my,
Hey,
I used to be an accountant baby.
You know,
like I like how lies for Chris Ryan immediately translate it.
Why else?
Why else would you like nothing else is worth it,
you know?
I guess to get a better job or something.
Maybe that would be something.
I don't want a job.
My entire life has been about avoiding ever having a job other than blow job
writing books.
Even just like,
God,
let me just get this out of the way so I don't have to have a job.
Dude.
I don't ever want to write another book in my life even that I'm trying to get
out of.
That's hilarious.
But you're an author,
you're in luck.
Stablish this successful author and you're like,
fuck,
I don't even want to do that,
dude.
I wrote a book and suddenly was running a business.
Like I never wanted to have a business.
I'm not a business guy.
What is the business,
Chris Ryan ink and yeah.
You know what it's like if you're in the paper,
suddenly managers are calling you and lawyers and you've got account,
you've got the sort of parasite infrastructure they'd gloms onto you.
Like you know those things on the bottom of boats,
you know,
and it's like no offense to any accountants who are parasites,
but you know what I mean?
And I mean,
you know,
Joe Rogan enterprises is a huge thing,
and you must be a mistake a lot of time,
a lot of attention.
And so even in my,
you know,
micro scale,
it's just a giant pain in the ass.
It certainly
can be.
Fortunately for me,
I don't think of anything that I'm doing as like really work work.
Yeah.
You know,
it's just stuff I enjoyed doing.
That happens to be an occupation rather than,
but yeah,
I mean what you're doing,
you're at a level where you can afford to hire good people to help you.
[inaudible] I'm not,
and my wife is useless,
so I mean,
she's a wonderful woman,
don't get me wrong.
And she's very good at certain things,
but you know,
producing a podcast,
editing a book,
right?
You know,
this kind of stuff I need someone to do.
I mean I have to answer her emails,
you know,
she can't be bothered
when you,
when you hear a guy like this rent as easy story,
when you hear a lie,
does that,
does it freak you out?
And you know what,
here's the thing that freaks me out and it freaks me out.
Like even like the Jared from subway thing or when I read something about some
guy who was messed up,
I forget what the article was about.
I think what the article was about,
a guy who was friends with the guy who turned out to be a murderer and it's
about a guy who got messed up.
And and gotten involved in some rough sex with some prostitute and killed her
and then solder up and left her fucking body and bags and shit.
It could've been an accident.
What whenever I hear about anybody who's just gone completely off the rails like
that,
I always say,
okay,
if I was that guy,
if I was born in his shoes,
if I lived his life,
would I have been that fucking guy?
Like how much of what we are is determinism.
You know,
how much of what we are is based on the events that took place,
that have,
that are completely outside of our control about how much of it is how we were
raised.
I mean we've all heard people tell like terrible stories about how their parents
raised them.
Terrible stories about the environment they're forced into and you always wonder
like how much of who each one of us is.
It is based on a bunch of shit that's completely outside of your control and how
much of these events
that take place,
whether it's the Jared from subway thing or I had my friend Barry Crimmins on
who's this,
a great comedian and a real icon in Boston and Bobcat Goldthwait did a film on
him about his horrific childhood sexual abuse.
He was raped when he was four years old by his babysitters boyfriend and it was
this horrific,
horrific story.
And you know,
this is something completely outside of this guy's control and how much of who
he is now is based on how well he's like in his fifties and this is like still
some things he's dealing with from when he was four.
You know,
it's just you,
you are now is like this series of these series of events that have kind of,
a lot of them just laid out in front of you without you having any control over
it at all.
Now here you are.
And when I see a guy that does something really crazy,
I mean this is like minorly crazy.
We're not talking about a horrific crime,
like a bill Cosby thing or something like that.
We're back to the comedian.
The comedian.
Yeah.
Thought the chopped up process.
I mean,
Steve Run is easy.
My friend,
you know,
w w w it's what he did was just doesn't make any sense.
Like,
and you just wonder like what?
It must be like fuck to be that guy who's done that.
It was just like said this thing for no fucking reason.
That doesn't make any sense.
And then it has to stick with it.
Just I don't,
I mean that's my angle on these things instead of getting upset about me.
Especially this one.
But how does that relate to what you're saying?
Do you feel like if you may,
if you were in the position he was in,
you might've done something similar?
I always worry that,
yeah.
I always,
whenever I see someone do anything crazy like murder or craziness or anything,
I always say,
well,
how much of who you are is because of your life experiences with a lot of them
outside of your control,
your genetics,
your parents,
the,
the environment that you were raised up in,
the people that you came in contact with when you were younger,
how much of that is who you are today in 2015 I think it's,
God damn it.
I think it's a lot.
Yeah.
And so I see this guy,
you know,
my friend,
and again,
Steve,
Ron is easy.
What he did was just dumb.
It's not evil.
It's not,
nobody got hurt,
you know?
I mean,
he might've hurt someone's feelings.
People that actually were survivors of nine 11 and the pretend that's
potentially possible.
But you know what I mean?
He didn't rape anybody.
He didn't murder anybody.
It's just fucking what happened.
How does that,
how's the brain gets so sick?
Fucking tweaked.
So in of the lies,
he's been busted for the,
I was in the twin towers at nine 11 is the one that everyone's focused on.
And no one gives a fuck about lying about working for Maryland.
Right.
Although I don't understand why you would write,
like you said.
And also like,
you know,
I,
I
would argue that anyone who was a survivor of nine 11 who was actually there has
bigger issues think about than social media and is,
so I would argue he didn't really hurt anyone except himself now that he's
busted rationally.
Yeah,
you're right.
So who gives a shit?
You know,
and everybody,
everybody in public life is lying on some level,
right?
You're,
you've got a persona and you have to be true to that persona even.
I mean,
I remember when I first sat down with this producer to talk about doing a TV
show and,
um,
which ultimately never got made like most TV shows.
But,
um,
when we were like putting together the,
the whole,
um,
uh,
Cha,
the summaries of the episodes and all this stuff,
he said,
so what's your,
you're on air,
who are you going to be on the show?
And I said,
what do you mean it's like a,
I'm just going to be me.
He said,
no,
are you going to be like the funny guy you're going to be?
They're really smart,
Pref,
professorial guy.
You know,
what's your image,
your persona going to be?
I said,
I'm just going to be me.
He said,
oh you're,
you're going to be authentic with with air quotes.
I said,
what the fuck is that?
No,
I'm going to be authentic.
He's like,
no.
On TV you can't be really authentic the most.
You can be as quote authentic because you have to be the same every fucking
episode and if you come in one day and you're feeling pissed off cause you just
had a fight with your wife or you know you got diarrhea or whatever the,
whatever your issue is,
you can't express that you have to be the same guy you were last week.
But why is that?
Cause that's just didn't,
well it's entertainment medium.
The medium is just so limiting in that way that people expect that every week.
That's the one of the cool things about a podcast is that they kind of don't,
like when you do 10,
generally speaking,
you can kind of like,
oh thank you bu nice.
Yeah,
I tried to but,
but still I am conscious of the,
did the distinction between who I really am and who people are getting the
impression I am.
And I try to be like just a last episode I did a,
in the intro I did a little thing about,
um,
cause people were writing to me and saying like,
what's it like to go from like some nobody in Barcelona to Ted talks and Grogan
show and all this stuff.
Right.
What's that like?
Did you like feel it happening?
Did you expect it?
Did you,
is it like being on a river and it was just flowing that way or were you
swimming toward it?
You know,
and so I tried to address it a little bit and what I said was in my very
minuscule experience,
fame is like wine that tastes really good and can only get you drunk.
Well,
it's in your mouth,
so you swallow it quickly.
I know it's not the best thing.
I think the other metaphor,
I thought it was like,
oh,
I can't.
Okay.
So if it's in your mouth,
it gets you junk,
but if you swallow it,
you're fine.
Fine.
Right.
Okay.
So you,
um,
I mean,
you
know what I'm talking about.
Someone comes up to you and like,
they're like nervous and like,
oh my God,
it's Joe Rogan,
right?
And you're like,
yeah,
I'm just,
I'm just me.
Right?
I mean,
you know the truth and you're just the guy,
but they're reacting to what they think you are,
which is so much more than what you actually,
what anyone is.
You know,
that's the nature of fame.
It's this bullshit thing that only has the value that people apply to it.
Right.
And they're applying more to it than you are because you're,
you.
Right.
And you know what it's like behind the curtain.
So,
but you don't want to disrespect them either.
Right.
And you don't want to disrespect what it is that they're experiencing in that
moment,
even though it's complete bullshit.
Right,
right,
right.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking.
No,
no,
you're making sense.
Cause it,
it,
it's,
it's very confusing to people that don't know it,
but it's,
it's like a magic trick that,
um,
if it tricks the magician,
he's a fucking idiot.
You know what I mean?
It's like you have some magic look,
I pull it up out of my hat.
You know,
there was no fucking dove and the doves and your sleeve ass hole,
you're hiding the dove.
I see what you're doing,
you know what you're doing.
But if you say,
I have this amazing ability to make doves appear out of nowhere and you really
believe it,
well you're a moron.
You know,
it's like you have a magic trick and being on television or being,
you know,
on the radio or in movies or whatever it is,
whatever it is that people get attracted to you by your work,
by your,
by you being an author,
whatever it is,
that thing makes you different than another person.
Instead of just like,
I appreciate talent,
like very much so,
and I can kind of be like a little star struck when I meet someone that I really
appreciate or that I really am,
uh,
admiring of their work,
but I kind of know what it is.
It's like I've seen it enough times that I will go,
hey,
there's that guy that fucking sings out.
Awesome Song.
Hey,
I love your shit,
man.
It's like,
it's a good thing,
but it's not,
I don't think of them as,
other than a human being.
But I remember one of the first times ever met a famous person or the first
times I ever met famous people.
I couldn't believe I was seeing them in real life.
One of the first guys that ever met,
I was in Harvard Square in Cambridge.
I don't even remember the dude's name,
but he had been in a bunch of like television dramas,
Fleming,
and I was like,
you're that guy from that show.
And he like,
tell me what the show is asking a question.
You're like,
want to know what the t stop was?
You know,
we could,
uh,
catch public transportation.
You know,
he approached you.
He just,
he was just,
yeah,
he asked a question,
asked.
I don't know if I asked him if he was that guy first or if he asks me,
but he didn't give a fuck.
He was like,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm that guy from that show.
Did you guys know where this thing is?
And we told them where it was and like,
wow,
we just saw that guy.
I still to this day,
don't remember who the fuck he was.
It's funny.
And when I was little,
my uncle used to work for Howard marks advertising.
My uncle Vinny is a,
an artist and he,
uh,
worked for the company that drew the album covers for kiss.
So when I was like Paul,
I guess I was like eight or nine years old maybe,
I don't know how,
somewhere in
that age I met,
uh,
ace freely who was the lead guitarist to kiss and he always wore makeup and I
met him with no makeup on and uh,
you know,
he would come by and like he,
it was a great hustle.
They had,
they wore makeup when they were on stage,
but then offstage,
no one knew who the fuck they were.
Huge superstar selling out arenas,
stars.
But they were just completely in Cognito others.
So this guy just walks into the office and my uncle knew him because they were
friends and he's like,
Oh hey,
what's up?
How are you doing?
And I was so confused.
I was like,
is that,
is that what he looks like?
Like you can,
cause he couldn't even see them.
Like they,
this was obviously pre internet,
but there was no photos of them available without their makeup.
It was like maybe one photo with like a hand in front of them or something like
that.
Well,
you really couldn't see clearly,
but to see him in the flesh moving around and walking and talking,
I was like,
what the fuck?
I thought about that for years.
It's a pretty cool thing because they,
I mean I don't,
I don't know anything about kiss.
Like if they were in masks from the beginning,
like with the makeup from plan clothes and stuff.
So like were they anticipating like wow,
if we get famous,
you know,
we don't want to be recognized that the whole foods,
like they see that shit come in.
They saw whole foods and trader Joe's.
It's all out there.
I don't think so.
I think there was a style of,
I think they used to call it Glam rock.
Is that what they used to call it with David Bowie and all that?
Yeah,
I mean I think that's what it's called,
but I think it was just a hook.
I think their hook was that they were going to wear face paint,
you know,
and have these designs in their face.
Like Paul Stanley was the star child,
so he had the star over his face and gene Simmons was the demon used to spit
blood and blow fire on stage and they have,
you know,
Pete or Chris was the cat and the ace freely was,
he had a,
he was like the space man and they have this persona that they had adopted like
these characters and no one knew what they were.
And all their names were fake too.
I'm pretty sure.
So like who they were when they were on stage and it was sort of taken even
further into fantasy land by this makeup and these crazy costumes that they
wore.
Like they were boots like gene Simmons,
boots had teeth on the bottom of them.
Like these.
It's just all so nutty.
So bringing it back to your buddy,
imagine you know your kiss and you're trying to pick up a woman in a bar and
you're like,
you know,
I'm gene Simmons,
the Fuck Outta here.
You probably work at Merrill Lynch.
I think they probably had so many girls coming up to them.
They never went to a bar and tried to meet people.
They never went.
Yeah,
I mean there was probably just trying to think how many can I fuck in a day and
how many do I have to say no to because it's just not going to work out as you
get tot do that for you.
Probably.
Yeah,
they probably had like
handlers,
handlers wranglers.
I heard an interview the other day with,
um,
uh,
I'd have him forget his name,
but he's one of the main guys of iron maiden and a,
which has a band,
I don't know,
but I know they're huge.
Right.
And he's a jet pilot and he flew commercial airlines for years.
So he was like,
you know,
nobody knew it was me up there,
and I just be,
you know,
flying,
London to New York or whatever.
Like this is your pilot and we're reaching out to cruising altitude and then
he'd go like play a Gig in New York.
So he would fly as a commercial air pilot and then do a Gig and then they bought
it jet,
you know,
seven 47 or something to fly the band around.
So now he flies the bands to gigs.
How fucking strange didn't John Travolta fly commercially for Quantus?
That rings a bell.
Yeah I know he's an accomplished pilot.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure he did.
A friend of mine went flying with Tom Cruise.
He's got like a one of those biplanes stunt plane.
Wow.
It was like loop de loop and she said man I almost puked on him cause she was in
front of,
you know the pilots and back and she was like I was this close to to Ralph and
all over time.
Great.
So the pilot goes in back and the passengers in front.
Right.
How strange.
Yeah.
Those old planes man.
When you,
it kind of,
when you see what it is,
this like wire frame with this like very thin coding outside of its sold.
The cable is going out to the flaps and stuff.
Yeah.
And they used to have to manipulate the flaps with handles in order to make it
go up and down and move on.
Right.
Oh God.
And they fought with those things.
You remember the kink old King Kong King Kong one with a King Kong on top of the
World Trade Center was the World Trade Center was the empire state building back
down.
Lied about the Ham.
Fucking liar.
He's climbing up the empire state building and they're shooting at and went
those planes.
So some old Ricky world war one is pre world war two because King Kong I believe
was the thirties the original case early,
I want to say like 33 or something like that.
It was a talkie,
right?
Yeah.
It was a tall one.
Early Talkies.
We went over that yesterday that the first movies were actually 18 hundreds for
silent movies.
There's late 18 hundreds with the horses.
The first one to show that the horses,
all the horses feet came off the ground at once.
No,
no.
That story.
Yeah.
I think that was the first motion picture.
I know a French guy.
Yeah.
There was a bet that it's a long time since I,
I may be full of Shit here,
but I'm sure people are googling it even as we speak,
but there was a,
I think it was the first motion picture was um,
that they were trying to determine whether all of the horses feet came off the
ground at once.
So he set up,
I don't know if it was like a bunch of cameras in a bank that sequentially shot,
well,
they have a video of it.
Actually we go an 89 there you go.
Yeah.
And the second frame you can see all the horses feet are off the ground.
What was the first movie ever made of the first movie?
A Thomas Edison in 1889 oh really?
Thomas Edison.
That's what this is saying.
It's too bad.
He was such a prick.
I apparently he was right.
He stole a Tesla's ideas.
Yeah.
It's hard to tell though.
That could be like one big,
he said,
she said thing,
but obviously Tesla was a super genius.
N Edison electrocuted a fucking elephant for fun to show to scare people.
Yeah.
Against DC,
which is hilarious.
Well against ACDC,
against alternating current like DC was what was the standard,
right.
And ACDC alternating current was what Tesla had invented so that you could plug
in all sorts of different devices that we need less power.
Oh,
I'm pretty sure the Edison already had a business thing.
And even though Tesla's idea was better,
more efficient.
Yeah.
Well Tesla was a weird,
weird,
weird guy,
man.
But you kinda have to be,
to be that fucking smart and figure out that many different things.
So that brings us back a little bit to what we were talking about before with
the,
you know,
the persona.
I've,
I've got this idea that most of the people who rise to positions of prominence
in Western society are troubled in some way.
So like,
you know,
you're talking about geniuses like you,
you have to be a genius is a certain kind of distortion.
Right,
right.
Um,
I think Einstein said that the,
a smart man controls his mind,
did geniuses controlled by it.
Right?
So you're,
there's an obsessive quality to it.
And I wonder if you know,
the extent to which our,
you know,
this,
this is the soul book that I'm writing is it seems that if,
if you say the underlying structure of civilization is essentially pathological,
then it makes sense that the,
the leaders,
the people who rise to prominent positions within that society will
predominantly be pathological.
Is that necessarily true?
Like is Zuckerberg like a guy who creates something like Facebook?
Is that kind of pathological?
Well,
you know,
you would,
I would look at him and say,
I don't know the guy.
Of course I just saw the movie that's as close as I got to him.
But uh,
does he seem like a balanced,
uh,
healthy character to me?
You know,
it seems like a lot of,
a lot of what's created is created by sexually frustrated adolescent men or boys
and he would probably fit into that area.
You know what I mean?
It wasn't the whole thing like a dating,
a way to meet chicks at Harvard.
Wasn't that the origins of it?
I think it was a dating,
I don't really know.
I don't remember.
It was in the movie.
Makes sense though.
Yeah.
So anyway,
I read Freud talked about this in civilization and its discontents that
civilization is built on deflected sexual energy.
And if we were all just getting laid as much as we want it,
nobody would do anything.
That's,
that's a good point.
And also if you really concentrate on what is healthy in quotes was healthy,
his friendship and fun.
None of those really stack up points,
you know,
as far as like monetary,
if you can wait,
you can put in your bank account,
right.
What you can show as far as like your real estate holdings and right.
The look at my fancy stuff.
Yeah.
You know,
like that,
that's really what people look to when they look for the gauge of success.
The gauge of success is almost always attached to money and that's it.
And if you get to the point where you see through money or fame or power these,
these Burton,
these metrics that are socially accepted,
then you become,
you know what the Jesus figure,
the Buddha,
the,
you know,
you sorta check out to in turn on drop out.
Right?
Yeah.
And then you're a loser.
You're a loser.
Exactly.
And you're not influencing,
uh,
the direction as society.
Yeah.
It's weird.
Like it's weird about our ideas,
like knowing the temporary nature of life.
It's weird that our idea of success is based almost entirely on the possession
of things.
Yeah.
And that of course feeds into the powers that be right.
The consumerist change,
the change in nature into plastic,
you know,
which seems to be what we're about.
I have a weird theory about this that I've repeated before.
So in interest of saving the,
the attention span of the people that listen,
I think that the reason why people are hooked on materialism and the reason why
it's so attractive is because ultimately what it's doing is propelling
technology and innovation and that the more we become obsessed with acquiring
the newest,
latest,
greatest things,
the more it will push innovation,
these newest,
latest,
greatest things.
And the reason for that is we're ultimately creating an artificial life.
And I think that we are the technological caterpillar that becomes some
artificial intelligent butterfly.
And that what we're doing is creating a new life form.
We just,
we're so,
we're so arrogant that we're,
we think that we're the only life and this is the only life it's possible.
But meanwhile,
what we're doing is we,
we,
we have been born into these inefficient,
um,
these biological entities,
these shells that how's our imagination and that we eventually will escape them
or create something that makes us obsolete more likely.
The latter.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm grappling with these very issues right now at the end of this book.
Right?
Yeah.
Have you ever read a Kevin Kelly or heard of him?
No.
He's,
um,
uh,
very deep
thinker and,
and,
um,
artificial intelligence and the Internet and all that kind of stuff.
Very interesting guy.
And,
and systems like how systems self organize and like,
you know,
like,
uh,
they take 'em high speed film of flocks of birds and they see that the
individual birds are reacting to other birds.
Um,
the flock is reacting quicker than individual birds can,
can react.
There's there,
there's what they call phase change,
um,
where you shift from a group of birds to a flock of birds or a bunch of fish to
a school of fish where the,
where everything starts functioning very differently.
Right.
And,
um,
like for example,
did you know that uh,
locus and grasshoppers are the same animal?
Yeah,
I did.
Completely crazy.
That gets to your earlier point.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
when,
when it rains and so then there's a lot of food they replicate,
you know,
they reproduce really quickly.
So now you've got the population density and then the food starts to dissipate
because the water is going and now they get very tight population density and
they become locus,
which their brains change,
their legs change,
the coloring changes,
their behavior changes and they start swarming.
So till with less food,
they swarm.
Yeah.
When the,
well the food is restricted so they get into,
um,
you know,
like a oasis or something.
So they get into smaller areas because the water from the rain,
first it rain,
so you get lots of them,
then the water,
uh,
starts to disappear.
Right.
It evaporates over a few days or whatever,
and the food is less and less.
So they're concentrated and it's when they're packed tightly that they shift
into locus and that's when they swarm and they go out,
you know,
and wipe out anything they can find,
but then they can shift back to grasshoppers again.
So I'm sort of arguing in this book that civilization is when our species
shifted to locus of a phase shift into a locust form.
And we swarmed and we've been swarming ever since.
But we're about to run out of material and you know,
like the fish stocks are down,
the water's gone.
Everything's,
we're in the age of no more.
You know,
it's hard to argue.
I was watching this documentary the other day about the 1970s when they were
talking about the 1970s there was 100 million less people in America,
in America and America,
and the world population was aliens.
That's stunning.
Yeah,
100 million.
I mean,
think about if 100 million people died today in America,
it would be a fucking enormous tragedy of epic proportion.
But that was just the numbers a few decades ago.
Yeah.
Four decades ago,
whatever it was,
you know,
whatever,
pick a number.
Yeah.
That's fucking crazy.
That's crazy.
To 100 million people is a lot gather in
inside of 50 years.
Yeah,
that's,
that's really remarkable.
And yeah,
and we're still talking as if growth is the natural and you know,
it's the way to,
it's the only way to be right.
We need growth.
We need growth there.
They're worried that,
uh,
reproduction levels are below zero in Japan,
in Spain and some other countries.
Why are we worried?
That's great.
I mean,
short term it's a problem because you don't have enough young people to work and
pay for the old people,
whatever.
But long term,
I imagine how great the fucking earth would be if there were 1 billion people on
earth.
You know,
that was something that came to Mckenna in a mushroom trip.
He,
he asked the mushroom how to save the human race and they said every couple
reproduce only with one child and the human race will be saved.
That's it.
It's all we'd have to do it significantly lower population and you know,
with mortality and accidents and natural causes and all the other jazz take
control.
Actually this is going to be historic.
I am a little,
I,
I'm at the end of the book,
right where I,
I the publisher requires a prescriptive like what's next?
You know,
what did we do with all of this kind of chapter,
which I hate doing,
but I'm doing it.
You have to like have a,
a solution take away their phrase that they love is what's the takeaway
takeaway?
Got To have a takeaway
that's of a final lap.
Mr. Ryan.
Yeah,
there's the gun's been on the mantle piece through the whole play.
Somebody's got to get,
you can't end the movie like no country for old men or just can't just,
the guy just wanders off and like,
what the fuck?
Where's the resolution?
Um,
but you know,
I've been reading Kevin Kelly reading other stuff and I've come around a,
you and Duncan and I have always had this sort of three way debate about the
future of humanity and all that.
And I see three scenarios,
one of which is the one you just outlined where we are a transitional life form
that gives birth to techno intelligence and spreads out into the universe in
whatever.
Um,
and uh,
the another is sort of apocalyptic collapse and mad men.
They're not mad,
mad,
Mad Max mad,
but that'll be come advertise different outfits.
I didn't lapels a lot of smoking.
Uh,
and uh,
but the other one,
which I'm actually,
you know,
if I were a betting man,
I probably wouldn't put my money on this,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm encouraged to think about it.
I read a book recently called future perfect.
Uh,
don't remember the author.
Steven Johnson is the author,
another Internet Tech Web guy.
Right.
And he makes us a really strong case,
which I've heard you make.
You've made it to me actually,
that the Internet is,
first of all,
it's very,
very early days for the Internet and it opens up
revolutionary possibilities like beyond anything that's happened to our species
in the past.
The fact that you and I right now are talking to hundreds of thousands of people
with no sponsor telling us,
don't say that.
Don't say this,
that I can,
you know,
we can talk shit about Monsanto,
we can talk shit about the u s government.
We can do whatever we want.
That is really revolutionary.
And the effects of that are impossible for us to really predict.
And it's international,
right?
It doesn't respect national borders.
It anyone,
anywhere.
It's archived.
It,
you know,
it,
it functions vertically and horizontally.
That's really something.
And one of the examples he uses in his book is Kickstarter.
In two years after they launched,
Kickstarter was already,
um,
spending more supporting artists than the National Endowment for the arts.
Wow.
Two years.
And now it's like three times that.
That's amazing,
right?
Who would have thought that there were so many people who are like,
I'll give 20 bucks to that guy.
I'll support that.
And you know,
this just with this technology,
you're able to do stuff.
I was reading about this tribe in the Amazon the other day who are,
um,
basically have taken over defense of their land because of the government's
useless and do so they've got legally they're completely justified,
but the loggers keep coming in and you know,
invading and so they've set up like gps units all around and,
and motion controlled cameras and uh,
they're using technology to try to defend their land and document in incursions
and stuff.
And I was thinking like,
what did it be cool to set up a crowdfunded thing where you could send 20 bucks
to this tribe in the Amazon to help them buy a fucking motion detected camera or
a drone?
Why not?
Right.
You know about Kiva?
No.
Kiva is micro loans.
Um,
and it's just a website like Kickstarter where you go in Kiva,
you put a hundred bucks in and um,
you,
they've got all these people who have applied for loans and you pick a country
El Salvador,
okay.
You go through,
you look at all the pictures and like,
okay,
I need 150 bucks to buy a goat cause I make goat yogurt and sell it in the
village.
Okay,
give her 25 bucks.
She pays it back there.
Their repayment rate is over 99% because they've got people in country who
verify that everything's cool and this is a real thing and whatever.
So then the money gets paid back to your account after they get their goat and
they sell enough yogurt and they,
and then you can either take your money out or you can recycle it and like go to
Uganda and let's find somebody in Uganda.
We can help them put a new roof on the shop rite and it's completely you to
them.
And the,
the company just,
you know,
is that,
it's like Tinder or anything else.
It's,
it's just a way to connect
really cool.
You know,
and it's your money and if you don't want to do it anymore,
you take your money and you're out.
Yeah.
These sort of non capitalistic ideas are one of the most beautiful things about
the internet.
Like these sort of organically created ideas like Kickstarter or crowdfunding
couchsurfing.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
uh,
yeah,
all this sharing economy,
he calls it,
it's,
his term is pure progressive's.
And so then like what's going to happen if,
you know,
we can get the,
the all the guards out of the way and make Internet direct voting.
That's the ultimate future,
right.
Internet direct voting where it's not no longer electorial college,
we don't look at things is in terms of states,
but we look at terms of the mass of the race or the mass of the human organism.
How does what benefit?
The problem is there's been people that have been candy fed,
they'd been baby fed for so long that it's almost like they're,
it's like taking a person who's been in solitary confinement,
locked up like a veal and then forcing them to run an ultra marathon.
It's like,
are you just writing?
You're not prepared for this.
You're not conditioned for it.
You don't have the resources to pull off a and informed version of the future,
you know?
Yeah.
But you know the,
and again,
it's really weird that I'm the,
I'm arguing the hopeful side here,
but hey,
what the fuck?
We said this is going to be a bullshit.
I ain't [inaudible] lie.
We're fucked.
I don't believe any of those.
Um,
the one thing I would say about human nature,
cause I get asked a lot,
what's human nature?
You know,
I think the strongest thing I can say about human nature is humans want to do
what everyone else is doing.
That's what we're really good at.
We're not good at thinking it through,
but like,
oh,
everyone else's killing Jews.
Well I guess I'll kill some Jews then.
You know,
like everyone else hates black people then I hate black people.
Gay Marriage is cool.
Okay.
Like,
look how fast that change.
Yeah.
I was going to bring that up when you were talking about the birds,
like the birds moving in a flock in a way where they're moving in such harmony
that they couldn't possibly be reacting to each other.
Right.
Is that what happens with mob mentality?
I guess so.
Yeah.
And I,
and I think,
you know,
in humans it's mob mentality.
It's fan like that hysteria,
Beatles,
the Beatles.
That's what I was thinking.
Yeah.
Like just insanity.
I mean,
there is,
you know,
the greater than the sum of its parts,
right?
That phenomenon.
Like there's no,
you know,
I mean,
geese are a different thing,
but most flocks of birds,
there's,
you know,
starlings,
you see doing that thing at night.
There's no leader,
right?
There's nobody saying,
hey,
let's go to the left now and now we're going to,
there's no choreography mimics and fish as well.
Right?
Sure.
Fish in,
in swarms of locusts.
And in fact,
in one of these books by Kevin Kelly,
um,
he talks about how they were doing the,
the artificial,
uh,
the guys who did the Batman,
one of the Batman movies and they were doing the special effects and I guess
they were bats.
There were flocks of bats that they needed to,
um,
replicate on screen.
And they,
they,
they just set up a logarithm where each bat would react to the other bats in,
near it,
in certain,
according to certain,
um,
uh,
variables.
Calculate calculations,
and then they just set it loose and it formed a flock.
Oh.
So it's like,
it doesn't even have to be alive.
It just has to have certain,
uh,
consistent responses.
Wow.
Yeah.
So what the fuck are we talking about?
Well,
we're talking about human beings that we're moving in a mob mentality,
or do you think that we're a c?
I think,
I think the evidence is that we're a super organism more than,
than we're in an individual.
Yeah.
We'll see what I did in,
in the book.
And,
and you know,
I hope this is making people want to read it when it comes out.
Not like,
yeah,
I already heard all this shit.
But you know,
what I did was I started by saying,
your individuality is itself an illusion,
right?
Because 90% of your weight,
once you get the water out is made of no,
no,
not your way.
90% of your DNA of the DNA that can constitutes your body is not your DNA.
It's the DNA of microorganisms that live on an in you.
Right?
So I got into the whole,
the,
the whole,
um,
uh,
ecosys intestinal Fonda and you know,
and all that.
Yeah.
And it's,
so you couldn't exist without that.
So each of us is a community,
right?
So,
and then you go to the higher level and it's just the same thing.
You know,
the,
we,
each of us constitutes an organism as well.
We are part of this thing that we can't really see because you know,
we're part of it.
It's,
it's hard to,
it's like fish don't think about water,
you know?
Right.
And it's not considered because we always like to think of ourselves as
individuals,
but the evidence is there that we get insanely lonely when we're by ourselves.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
we can find me.
It's the worst thing you can do to someone in jail.
I mean,
it's really crazy.
And if you think about human beings like being isolated and being lonely,
and then the incredible joy that they have when they find civilization or people
like someone alone on a raft,
they're not thinking about while I'm alive,
at least let me just think about my life.
And I know they're like,
fuck,
I got to find people.
I have to find people again.
If you have all the food in the world,
if you're floating around on a boat,
lost at sea,
you're incredibly sad.
Like we have this insane intense need for each other to,
to be a United bonded with each other.
And if we're not,
we're,
we're fucked.
Yeah.
We're like,
we're some strange sort of super organism.
I
made a,
um,
a video when I had my 2005,
a showtime special and I did this video about flying over the earth.
And then if you fly into Los Angeles,
and if you look at the earth as a host for life,
and,
uh,
you know,
our bodies,
you could certainly say that our bodies are a host for life because of all the
organisms that we just talked about,
that the fact there's more e coli in your body,
then there are people that have ever lived ever.
I mean,
it's,
it's amazing and all that stuff is important for life.
Yeah.
But when you fly in Los Angeles and you're flying over that just gigantic mass
of cities,
like if the earth is an organism,
will what?
What are people,
what's it looks like a growth like Los Angeles looks like a growth.
It looks like a growth on the super organism,
like mold on a sandwich and if you saw mold on a sandwich,
you don't think of individual pieces of mold with individual identities and
personalities.
You just see mold.
I think the same thing could be said about human beings that were just so close
to it.
We can't see the forest for the trees that we don't see ourselves objective.
We don't go,
oh,
we're,
we're one thing or one big thing that's making technology.
I mean that's essentially what we are.
One big thing is willing to sacrifice the very fucking air.
The very air that we need to stay alive are willing to black in that shit up in
order to produce,
you know,
in industrial goods.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
I hope that's not the way it's going,
but it's sore.
It feels that way.
That's the trajectory we're on at the moment.
What I'm hoping is that the,
the Internet,
I mean I look at the gay marriage thing and a lot of this stuff is,
is ugly that happens on the Internet,
but the idea that there is for the first time ever,
the potential for an org,
a species mind,
you know,
a species level mind,
what's the first thing any conscious mind becomes aware of its own mortality.
So maybe maybe what's happening is as the,
these synapses are connected for the first time ever and there's this super mind
for a super organism.
It becomes aware of what is what it's doing and suddenly it's like fuck,
stop this.
This is crazy.
We're killing ourselves.
If we can understand that at a species level then we can change it.
Right?
I mean we,
the the passive technologies there,
we all know how to,
you know,
anal sex is better,
let's make anal sex the way to no more reproduction.
Let's all go.
I'm not going to talk about it
fucking crazy.
Well no I know,
I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
I think the idea non reproductive sex sodomy is where it's at.
You saw tummies where it taught be a good teacher.
It's a lot.
There's a lot of protein and come to you know,
doesn't necessarily have to eat chickens by the way.
You were,
I saw your Ronda Rousey interview.
Yeah.
And you,
you really funny you said the,
what is it with lipstick,
you know,
it's like right here.
This is where the Dick goes,
right?
I was thinking,
you know,
that is why and how lipstick was invented.
Egyptian hookers,
you know that it was hookers.
Yeah.
It was Egyptian hookers to advertise that they specialized in blow jobs.
Wow.
So if you saw hooker with a red lips is like,
she's uh,
she's the blowjob specialist.
Wow.
How do we know that?
Was that written somewhere?
Probably Hieroglyphics.
You know,
I,
I trust the,
I read it in the history of sex by somebody or other,
we lost so much of what Egypt was all about and they burned the library of
Alexandria.
He's lost.
It's incredible because if you,
if you see what they were able to accomplish,
so much of what archeologists and historians do when they go back and they look
at what Egypt,
what they were accomplishing,
it's like we're trying to figure out why and how the fuck all this stuff was
done.
You know what I mean?
All they have is what's left on the walls.
It's so crazy.
All they have,
literally they have the Rosetta stone and they have the hieroglyphs and they
have the,
the architecture and then they have to try to like back engineer and decipher to
this day there's like a dozen different theories about how they built the
pyramids.
They just really just guesswork.
It's not aliens.
I thought it was aliens.
I don't think that's true.
I don't either.
I think it's much more likely the advanced civilization a rise and decline is
much more likely.
And as,
um,
as we're learning more about geologic,
uh,
our,
catastrophes as we're learning more about a asteroidal impacts and things along
those lines,
it's way more likely that what you're looking at when you're looking at a lot of
the ancient structures that exist that we can't totally explain was that
something happened that like civilization had reached a very high level and then
probably were hit by giant rocks from space and very few people survived.
But the people that did survive sort of re figured out all the things over a
course of a few thousand years,
just like we have.
I mean,
you go back a thousand years ago,
okay,
let's just go a thousand years ago,
go back to 1015 people were apes.
I mean,
you're talking about like Genghis Khan,
they're riding horses.
No one's got a car,
this shooting arrows at each other.
No one's got guns.
I mean,
this,
you're talking about craziness.
You're talking about a crazy part of the world.
They have catapults and shit.
That was what the world was just a thousand years ago.
So in a thousand years we've gone from Gingiss con to fa,
Elon Musk making Teslas.
It's Great Kangaskhan to Elan Musk thousand years and we had essentially a
thousand years.
So Magine what we're talking about when the like,
um,
I've had Randall Carlson on my
podcast who is a fascinating guy who is absolutely obsessed with asteroidal
impacts and he studied them his entire life and as time has gone on,
more and more of his work has been vindicated,
especially by core samples.
He believes that there is enough proof that the stone that the ice age ended
because of asteroidal impacts.
And he had thought this way before they had figured out this stuff call,
I think it's called Triton night.
They found evidence of a,
what they call nuclear glass,
all throughout Europe and Asia.
And it all is around 12,000 years ago.
It's all around the same time the ice age ended and he thinks it was the
catalyst for the end of the ice age and probably wiped out a gigantic chunk of
humanity that there was just massive asteroidal impacts all over the planet.
And that the just fucking killed almost everybody or a huge percentage and
everybody who's left sort of how to refigure out how to make buildings where we
figure out how to engineer society.
And then they were left with the skeletons,
the architectural skeletons of the past.
You know,
they would look at Stonehenge or look at,
you know,
uh,
go Beckley Tapi or any of these giant ancient structures and go,
what the fuck was,
what's this all about?
Who did this,
how'd they do this?
And they would try to mimic it or create their own.
And that what you're looking at when you look at many of these ancient
structures,
it's just whatever would be left when a giant chunk of civilization is wiped
down.
People have to start all over,
right?
Yeah.
Ever read a book called the world without us.
I've heard of it.
It didn't read it.
It's a good book.
It's basically taking that same thought pattern and applying it to now.
So what would happen if people all disappeared right now?
And so he,
he talked to engineers in New York for example.
Like,
so what would happen,
like right now,
nobody there,
no people.
What would happen?
Well,
the pumps would stop and there are all these pumps that keep water out of this,
the substructure of Manhattan.
Right.
So then that fills up with water.
Okay.
Then how long does it take for the,
the,
um,
uh,
anchors and the skyscrapers to rot or rust away and corrode?
So the skyscape or start falling.
And so he figures all that out.
Like what animals would go feral and survive versus dogs or fuck that all dogs
would be eaten.
Like immediately.
Cats would survive though.
Oh yeah.
What about feral dogs?
Like they have,
there's populations of feral dogs that exist even in America today.
Like,
yeah,
they killed some old couple.
I guess they'd beat George.
That makes sense.
Better predators,
right?
Yeah.
More adapted.
Probably damage is done left.
Yeah.
I met a guy in Colorado that is a professional mountain mine hunter and uh,
they get hired,
uh,
oftentimes,
like whether or not you knew it.
California employees,
professional mountain lion killers.
Wow.
Because they don't have a hunting season on mountain lions in Colorado or in a
California rather in Colorado they do.
And they,
the the,
the wildlife organization,
they measure the population,
the calculated and they decide how many would be viable to take to keep the
community of them healthy,
but to protect the elk population and the deer population.
And so then they adjust accordingly and they release tags and tags with the
hunters used to go out and legally kill these animals.
Well California doesn't have that.
So in California they have,
I think he said three different guys that kill an indeterminate amount of
mountain lions and he trouble mountain lions.
They have all throughout California they just travel around and kill these
fucking things because if you don't then they overpopulate and then they become
a problem with dogs and people and joggers and shit like that.
But there's groups in California in particular like extreme wildlife advocates
that want,
that they want no more hunting.
And what they want to do is reintroduce wolves and grizzly bears to California
so that those animals control all the game populations to a sufficient level,
which is a really,
like,
it's not very well thought out because then no one controls their population
except assassins.
They have to hire assassins to go out and kill the grizzly bears that start
encroaching into civilization and the wolves and start moving in on people's
livestock.
They have to hire people to kill them.
But it's,
this is fascinating idea of a animal management that these,
these people are like juggling back and forth with machine.
The people that are pro hunting and then the people that are,
um,
the conservationists or the wildlife advocates.
It's really fascinating stuff.
Yeah.
You remind me of something I just read recently about the Cobra effect.
It's called,
it refers to the unintended consequences of trying to control wild animals.
And it started when the British were in India,
in New Delhi.
Uh,
the local authorities decided to deal with the fact that there were all these
cobras living in the sewers and you know,
causing a big problem.
So they instituted a price for each dead Cobra that you would bring in and
they'd pay you a bounty.
Right?
So that worked really well.
They were getting rid of a lot of cobras.
Then people started breeding them to make money.
Absolutely.
So suddenly there are all these covers coming in and they realize they're being
played.
So then they're like,
fuck that.
And they stopped paying the bounty.
So now the breeders have thousands of Cobra as you know.
And so just let them loose.
Oh Jesus.
So you end up with a much bigger problem than you thought you were resolving.
Well,
Australia has done that yet Matt
to Australia had a problem with,
uh,
they,
Australia didn't really have large mammals.
Uh,
or rather,
I'm a New Zealand didn't really have large mammals,
but Australia introduced certain predators to try to deal with,
introduced animals like rabbits,
right?
Like they introduced rabbits to Australia,
but they didn't have natural predators.
So they brought over foxes.
And then the Fox is eight a shitload of rabbits and then got out of control and
started eating ground nesting birds and decimating
the population of ground nesting me.
You can't tell,
you can't engineer a fox to only eat rabbits.
Right.
But they never did get ahold of the rabbit population.
The rat,
they put up fences to try to stop the rabbits from moving into new areas,
but they weren't quick enough.
And the rabbits got through the fences as they were building the fences.
The rabbits fucked their way through to the other side of the fences and just
fucked and made more and more rabbits.
And then they wanted to introduce a fox is over there and then they wanted to
bring in predators to kill off the foxes.
Like it's a cluster fuck of human beings trying to somehow or another managed
nature and every time he gets away.
Yeah,
true predators and especially things like,
like a rabbit that can just breed like crazy in an environment where they,
you know,
they did really didn't have a natural enemy.
There's a great documentary called cane toads about the same thing in Australia
where they,
there is some grub that was eating,
they're destroying sugar cane and in Hawaii they're able to grow sugar.
And the,
the Grub is under control because they have these big toads that eat the grub.
So they brought the cane toads to Australia and introduce them.
And these toads,
they're like that big.
They're,
they're,
I mean,
they're like the size of a 16 ounce steak,
you know,
they're massive.
Great.
What a fucking,
that's a frog and they're everywhere or,
and they've just like gone crazy.
And the movie is really funny because it's like these people in their encounters
with these cane toads and they're Australian,
so they're just naturally funny.
And can you eat them?
No,
no.
But they do have boof Latina.
If you look at them,
you can get really high.
Ah,
but if your dog bites one,
kill your dog and wow.
Yeah,
there.
So,
yeah.
Yeah,
it's it.
I Dunno man.
It,
it makes you think like,
you know,
the whole super organism idea is one of those.
There you go,
look at that thing.
It's bigger than a steak fucking price that it's so big.
It's so big.
It does.
It looks like I like a,
a large bass.
And the movies,
so funny,
it opens,
there's this scene,
it's like early morning and the,
the,
the fog is sort of,
it's foggy hillside and there's a road and you see this van coming down the road
and it sort of swerving around.
It really is swerving around and gradually realized that he's running over as
many cane toads as he can and they're all over the road and he's like,
he's hitting these gains and he talks about how if you hit it just right where
like where it's facing the van and you seal its mouth,
it pops and there's this big explosion,
right?
Yeah.
I have so many of them that they just run over him and the road,
they're everywhere,
man.
And they,
and it's the same thing as you were talking about.
They don't eat the grubs,
they eat everything else.
They might state rats,
they eat all sorts of shit and they have no natural predators and they're
poisoned and they're poisoning.
That's out of control.
And what's the proposal to try to manage
that?
I don't know what they're doing now.
I saw this movie like 20 years ago at the Margaret Mead Film Festival in New
York and I've lost track of the cane toad issue since then.
I'm sure.
Do you know what happens with rabbits at every seven years?
Rabbits have a die off.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Rabbits apparently all like farmers and ranchers who tell you they go in these
great cycles,
these seven year cycles and right now the population and a lot of areas is very
high.
Where I was in Colorado th this is where the guy was explaining you were just
there like two days ago or something.
Yeah.
And the guy who I was with,
um,
he,
he explained it to me,
but I had heard it from a few people before that um,
their populations get extremely high and then a disease comes along and wipes
them out and it's clockwork.
It happens every seven years and then you find very few rabbits and then seven
years later it will be a swarm again.
It just takes a few years for them to rebuild back up and then their back.
And then the same thing happens again.
A new disease kicks along and maybe the same disease,
I don't know.
But the cycle of die offs of a great population growth and die offs.
And this guy was arguing that I was hanging out with in Colorado.
He was saying,
you know,
it's quite likely that what we're looking at is a natural cycle and that it
could be applied to the human race as well.
Yeah,
there's a beautiful book,
which I've recommended many times called a short history of progress by Ronald,
right.
Canadian scientists and it,
he looks at every civilization that's existed.
Uh,
you know,
the Mayans,
the Sumerians,
a,
the Romans,
the Easter island,
all these different civilizations and he shows that they all follow the same
lifecycle.
It's exactly what you're saying,
that there's an organic rise and then there are certain conditions that happen
that just naturally one follows the next and then the decline.
And you know,
you see it happen again and again and again.
Yeah.
It's like the,
the,
the tide,
you know,
it's in the town.
It seems to be like a cycle that exists just in almost everything in nature that
there's,
there's some sort of a balancing factor that occurs with any system where you
get an accumulation of one particular species or one particular thing and then
it dies off and then it comes back.
And I mean,
it could be argued that that's what the asteroid will impact is that it's some
sort of an,
an inoculation from space.
Well,
and also life apparently came from asteroids.
Yeah.
So Burmese.
Yeah,
exactly.
The theory that the building blocks of life,
like simple life,
like the amino acids and all those things came by stars.
And then when you find out that a human being really,
essentially it's made out of star dust,
in order to have carbon based life forms,
you have to have a star explode.
You're going to start singing it.
So it's too crazy,
man.
I started,
uh,
um,
it's a fucking shit.
Joni Mitchell.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of them.
Um,
by the way,
while we're talking about carbon and got to get back with regard to the guy.
Yeah.
Crosby stills Nash yesterday.
What was his name of that song?
Uh,
Woodstock,
Woodstock at the time we got to Woodstock.
We are starting to us.
We are gold and we are a billion year old carbon.
We've got to get our way back to the garden.
It's a beautiful song.
It was,
they were hippies.
I loved their son.
Acid.
Dirty feet.
Love the one you're with.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
Uh,
it's the theme song to sex at dawn.
It should like,
you should get a CD with the book or something.
It's funny,
I've met quite a few girls who have read your book and uh,
when they do read your book,
there's one of two reactions.
One reaction is fuck that guy.
And then the other reaction is it's time to be a Ho.
It's time to just go out and get your freak on.
I was talking to this comic like couple of weeks ago and she was saying,
if you're a read this book,
it's called sex at dawn.
I go,
yeah,
I go to authors,
a good friend of mine,
and she goes,
fucking so right.
It's so right in that immediate like,
oh,
there's a Frigo.
She's a freak.
Like finally somebody gave her her freak license.
Exactly.
Somebody came along with a phd next to his name and said,
it's okay.
Do what you do.
It's all right.
Oh Man.
I've gotten so many beautiful emails from women.
Um,
you know,
I've gotten some anger he wants to,
but some really beautiful ones from women who say,
you know,
like,
and even some of the most moving ones are the ones where they say like,
I get my mom now.
You know,
that's what really touches me.
like I get it all right.
She wasn't bad.
She just liked to fuck,
you know,
and not funny.
And in those days that was a big problem.
You know,
it's a weird thing that we,
we have such a conflicted relationship with.
On one hand,
we sell everything with sex.
We use it to sell cars and fucking houses and everything is so much so that a
normal look for a woman,
normal in a business environment is exposed legs.
Just think about what kind of a business environment would it be of men walked
around with thongs.
It wouldn't exist.
I mean it'd be like the fuck are you doing?
Men had like little short skirts that they wore to work where your cock was
just,
you could just lift up the shirt,
the skirt and your cock would be right there.
That that's not acceptable.
But we women are so desirable and sex is so desirable that we have accepted this
idea that a woman's attire could be like the easiest possible thing to fucking
like literally panties that you just pulled to the side and a skirt.
You just lift up easy accidents on fun high heels,
which flips your rear entry,
you know,
and I'll draw what's a bra,
you know?
I mean it's like here it is.
It's
a tit show,
tits shelf.
It's,
yeah,
this letting everybody know it's right here.
Come and get it.
And yet on the other side,
you know,
there,
and,
and none of this is to say that women,
uh,
should buy into this if they don't want to or that,
you know,
uh,
objectifying,
I mean,
objectifying is a,
is a complicated thing.
I think we all objectify constantly.
Um,
but you know,
like this guy,
there's a big controversy.
A week or so ago,
some guy,
a woman sent in a lawyer in England sent,
uh,
tried to contact a senior lawyer in,
in this firm through Linkedin,
uh,
to get a job.
And he wrote back and said,
well,
we don't have a job right now,
but I'll tell you your photo is stunning and you know,
I'm sure you'll have lots of success.
And so then she calls him out for sexual exploitation because he said her photo
was stunning.
That was it.
That's just a compliment.
Yeah.
Is that all he said?
He didn't like,
not,
not like,
let's have dinner,
nothing.
Just like your photos thing.
So it became this big deal.
And,
uh,
and the guy like,
you know,
half the people are saying the guy's a creep,
and I'll take creep shaming is an interesting thing.
Like if you're over 50,
you should never,
you shouldn't be sexual.
You shouldn't be sexual.
Yeah.
You like a 30 year old girl,
you piece of shit.
You're a pedophile.
Oh,
you creep.
She's 22.
Why would you be attracted to her?
She's a babe.
You Woody Allen,
you discuss,
you disgust me with your sexual desire.
A fucking Cialis induced heart on fuck you.
Speaking of,
speaking of,
uh,
standing up for people,
I really appreciated the article you wrote recently.
It,
where's the men's men's life for?
I don't know about hope.
Some maximum.
That was really nicely done,
man.
Thanks man.
Seriously,
as a guy who's not in great shape,
I appreciate it.
That,
yeah,
the,
the concept,
what they wanted me to write something about the human body,
uh,
about getting in shape or whatever,
and it just occurred to me to make the comparison to a human body and sand
castles and your body's like a sand castle.
That the reason why sand castles are kind of cool is because you know that
they're not going to last.
Yeah.
It was really well done.
And it's,
I mean it,
it called the Mandela,
the idea of building something beautiful that's going to be washed away as soon
as you get done with it.
I often think about life that way.
Not physically so much,
but um,
like I feel,
I,
I'm in my mid fifties now and I feel like I'm starting to figure it out.
Yeah.
That is part of the problem.
Right.
By the time you realize the hustle,
the fucking game was almost done.
It's like I'm learning how to dance and they're turning the lights on sort of.
Probably also what contributed to all these fucked up civilizations was the
people and they lived to be like 30,
you know,
if you were really lucky.
So you're just constantly on momentum like running where you couldn't stop.
I go,
ah,
and then the barbarian hordes cut your head off and then hopefully along the way
you fucked and left behind some of your genes and then they fucked up and people
just died off in these giant chunks.
When rats came into your cities have carried fleas,
it had the play.
And then finally we developed the ability to fight off diseases and Nakia late
ourselves from certain viruses,
uh,
build up walls to keep out the barbarians,
build up buildup stockpiles of food so that we didn't have to constantly hunt
and gather.
And then everybody went,
hmm,
I think if you make something circular,
we can roll it.
I'm going to call it a wheel.
And then they started pushing things along and then they start,
I mean,
you could argue that that agriculture and that civilization was the downfall.
But you could also argue it was the beginning of real thought.
It was the beginning of relaxed thought because you had the opportunity to
innovate well and you had the surplus of food that you could have people who
thought for a living.
Yeah.
And then the machines slowly started to plot our demise.
They started with the guiltless listening.
I could be a wheel man.
I can carry you to put anything,
make life easier for you.
Hey Dude.
You know,
if you just fucking make a silo,
you can put all your grain in the silo.
Yeah,
exactly.
You have stockpiles.
Next thing you know you've got Steve Jobs.
Oh yeah.
Let me,
I mean I remember in the must have been the 80s when my boss gave me a beeper
and I was like,
oh cool.
I get a beeper now and within two days it's like,
you might as well put a fucking leash around my neck.
You know?
It's like,
this isn't helping me.
This is for you.
You fuck.
How about people that are required to answer emails over the weekends?
There's a lot of jobs that you're required to answer emails at night over the
weekend.
You have to constantly be aware and you have to have your funders.
There are certain companies that require people that are employees to have their
phone,
where the notifications are turned on so that an emails come in for the company.
You have to instantly answer them.
Even when you're not at work,
you're working,
you,
there's jobs,
especially when it comes to silicon valley and these really very competitive
tech industries,
there's a lot of like debate as to when you should not have to answer an email.
Like,
when is it okay?
Like if your boss sends you an email at seven o'clock at night and you don't
respond till six o'clock in the morning when you wake up or whatever it is,
you could get in trouble and they're fucking drug testing you.
That drives me nuts.
You know,
you smoke weed fucking last weekend.
Yeah.
And you come to work and you,
you're like,
are you fucking kidding me?
This is slavery.
That one's nuts.
That is slavery.
We're moving back to Spain and you know,
are you oh yeah.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
this was always a,
a temporary visit.
This was a slow nomadic trip through North American Portland and then Spain.
Well,
it was,
I mean,
first it was Vancouver,
Canada,
and uh,
then we were in Nicaragua for the winter,
then we went back to Vancouver and then we came to la for the winter is when,
you know,
you and I had Dunkin
started doing the shrimp parade and all that.
I was living in Topanga,
but it's always like a slow move.
And then we went to Portland for a year and a half.
And now we're going to go back to Barcelona.
What made you decide to go back?
Yeah,
well we were always planning to go back.
I mean,
we,
we sort of flirted with maybe staying for a while.
Um,
but my wife's a doctor and for her to get a license in the u s would mean like
going back to medical school essentially,
which she's not going to do.
Right.
Um,
and she really likes working.
She hasn't worked in four years while we've been traveling.
So,
you know,
that's an issue.
Like if she's going to continue practicing.
Um,
but also just,
we really liked Spain.
You know,
I've lived in Spain most of my life.
Um,
I've lived in Barcelona longer than I've lived anywhere else.
And what is it about Barcelona that's more appealing in America?
You know,
when I first got to Spain,
I felt,
I,
I traveled a lot and I was actually on my way somewhere else,
but I got robbed and you know,
I ended up hanging out and the way Spanish people see life,
uh,
is much closer to the way I see life.
And so even though I was raised in America,
I never felt like this country never really made sense to me.
How so?
Well,
like what we're just talking about like work,
materialism,
you know,
it's all about the money.
Spanish people that,
you know,
the expression is we work to live.
We don't live to work.
Right.
Um,
you know,
there no,
like Spanish cars.
There's no cup holder.
If you want,
you want to get a drink,
pull over in a cafe and get a drink.
They're know to go cups.
You want a coffee,
go to a cafe.
They really,
yeah,
there's,
it's like someone should tell them about cups and lids on them.
The fuck is wrong with those tapes.
Crazy on the civilized.
He then fucking cave people,
um,
sack hops.
You know,
even though Spain is,
you know,
officially a Catholic country,
there's so much more chilled out about sex,
about,
uh,
sex outside of marriage,
like,
eh,
whatever.
Just don't tell me about it.
That's the sort of normal way to deal with it.
Um,
women,
no,
you look,
I've lived in Spain 23 years or something,
right?
I get accustomed when I see a beautiful woman.
I look at her and she knows I'm looking at her and she appreciates it and she
smiles and I smile and everybody's happy.
Come to America and look at a woman like that.
You're fucking rapist,
right?
You know,
I raping me.
If you heard that my question questions,
I mean,
fuck your micro aggressions.
I don't want to hear if you're not a fucking dwarf.
I don't want to hear about microaggressions.
Gimme a break.
I mean,
this country is just nuts,
man.
And like it,
and I feel bad because they're there.
I love people here.
I've got great friends here.
There are a lot of things I love about it.
Like,
you know,
work wise,
it's the best place to be.
But um,
lifewise fuck,
I love Spain.
You go out to lunch with a friend,
it's probably going to go till five or six o'clock did everybody just hangs out
the house?
Yeah,
no,
like restaurants,
right?
I'm sitting in a restaurant and a,
we're talking the waiter,
first of all,
the waiter's going to come four times and ask,
you know,
how is everything?
Oh,
are you,
oh,
how's your day going?
Fuck you get away.
I've tried.
I tried to talk to my friend here right then.
Then they'll come and say,
are you still working on that?
This isn't work.
This is fucking lunch.
But my work and on that get out of here,
drive me crazy tips,
20% I go to Portland,
I fucking,
you know,
buy a croissant and a cup of coffee.
There's a big tip jar I run my credit card did 10% 15% what?
You just handed me a fucking bag in a cup.
I'm supposed to give you 15% extra.
That's because your boss is to fucking cheap to pay you a decent wage.
That is true.
That is exactly what it is.
Yeah.
I like the tip thing because I like being generous.
I like the option to make someone happy by giving them a nice tip.
Right.
But it is kind of fucked it like waiters and waitresses don't even make minimum
wage.
Right.
That's,
I don't know if that's true anymore.
They're still true.
Yes.
True.
That's crazy to me that that seems rude.
It seems evil.
It seems illegal.
It's humiliating now too because they have to like smile and give you all this
fake cheerfulness.
There was an article that was written recently about that
that about the emotional toll of,
uh,
requiring people to be artificially happy and that it's not productive and that
like the artificially happy people that answer phones and ask questions and,
and how are you today,
sir?
And how's everything like requiring people to do that,
that work for you?
Not only is it not productive,
it,
it wears them out and it makes them less productive at other things that you
probably need them to because there's like,
um,
there's a,
a mental,
there's an energy that you need to do that,
that you could be doing and directing towards something that's actually
productive instead of like fake.
Alien is one thing.
You don't want to be rude,
but just being efficient is enough.
You don't have to have this like fake sort of smiley bullshit,
but that fake smiley bullshit people require it.
Like especially people who are customers.
The customer's always right,
like that kind of nonsense.
Like this relationship where the customer has to be like massage and catered to
instead of just appreciate as a fellow human being.
There's like an established relationship between the customer and the employee.
Your employee is rude,
sir.
I'm sorry.
Is there any way we can make it up to you?
I don't know.
I might be taking my business elsewhere,
whereas,
you know what I mean?
If that was about friendship,
you'd be like,
well go fuck off.
Make a new friend dickhead.
And in Spain,
that's the reaction.
You'll get it as well.
That's nice.
You go into a shop,
but see the in Spain,
I bitch all the time too.
Right.
So yeah,
I'll take it with a grain of salt.
But um,
I'm from Spain.
Well then where's the fucking waiter?
The people are rude.
It's exactly,
that is true.
That one,
the opposite.
This service is not as good.
It's just not,
no,
because they don't get paid tips and they don't give a fuck.
What should probably give a fuck.
Like this should be,
oh,
there's a middle ground there somewhere.
Yeah.
I think that is the middle ground.
Right.
I think like in Spain you go into a shop to buy whatever and the woman's on the
phone with her boyfriend.
She's going to finish your conversation before she comes to help you.
Right?
Yeah.
But I mean,
for example,
I went to Spain a few months ago to renew my residency paperwork and all that.
And it was a typically Spanish experience where,
you know,
this kind of thing in America,
you would,
you know,
go online and fill out this thing and you know,
call the IRS and be on hold and then you get some grumpy ass hole in
Philadelphia and,
but it would all get done pretty quickly in Spain.
You go to this office and they're like,
hey,
how are,
Ya know they're really friendly and nice and all.
No,
it's not this office.
You have to go to this other office.
Oh sorry.
Okay.
You go to the other office,
they're really nice,
but that's not the right office either.
They misinformed you and,
but nobody's got any like Mile Lha as they say in Spanish,
which is like bad milk,
literally,
which like bad intentions.
So it takes three days and it's kind of a pain in the ass,
but it isn't a painting ass because you're having fun all the time.
Everyone's nice.
The women are beautiful,
the cops are nice in Spain,
they're nice guys.
You can go up to a cop in Spain and be like,
hey man,
you know,
can I park here?
And he's like,
Eh,
I remember literally trying to park my motorcycle in the Ramblas and,
and it's no parking,
but there are motorcycles everywhere.
And there's this cop standing right there.
So I go over and I'm like,
I'm a foreigner.
Right?
Can I park my bike here or not?
And he says,
legally,
no,
but nobody will say anything.
But can you imagine an American cops and that maybe the 60s when,
when would that have ever been said in this catch?
You'd have to be a long time ago.
And see the,
the legal system is in Spain.
It's a problem if you're bothering someone,
not if you're breaking a law.
If you're breaking a law and nobody says anything,
the cops don't give a shit.
So in America,
it's the law.
It's did you break the law?
Are you growing weed on your terrorists?
We're flying helicopters with infrared detectors to catch you.
Not,
did your neighbors complain or did you shoot somebody?
Right in Spain,
like,
I grew weed on my terrorist for 20 years.
Nobody said a fucking word.
Nobody cared less weed,
legal in Spain.
Uh,
like a lot of things in Spain,
it's Kinda not kinda is.
And,
and this is a really important,
uh,
cognitive difference between Spain and the u s is tolerance for ambiguity.
Like,
like in Spain,
I'll tune in like,
oh,
there's a,
you know,
Barson Madrid soccer game,
really big deal,
right?
Starts at eight o'clock,
I'll turn on the TV at eight o'clock and there's still some fucking sitcom on
what's going on.
Well,
they running late,
you know,
the game will start in 10 minutes or,
it's just,
can you park here?
Well,
Eh,
you know,
there's a lot of ambiguity and no one really cares if it's not causing a
problem,
whatever,
to get to Ah,
whatever.
You know.
So we'd,
for a long time,
weed was illegal officially,
but the cops didn't care.
Um,
so like if you're smoking a joint on a playground and a cop walks by,
he's probably gonna say,
dude,
what the fuck?
Go,
go somewhere else.
Get away from this playground,
that kids here.
That's what would happen.
That's it.
If you give him shit,
then maybe it'll escalate.
But they have quotas.
No,
none of that.
No quote is no property seizures.
There's none of that stuff that's no minimum mandatory sentencing.
The property seizures.
Yeah.
People know about it.
They're mean.
I,
they've lessened considerably.
But those things are horrific.
And what they've done to people is they've,
they've dragged people into the legal system oftentimes when they're completely
innocent.
Yeah.
Property seizures and not necessarily in many states.
Even a result of them catching you with something illegal.
It's catching them with too much cash.
Like there's a lot of people that have gotten caught.
Some states,
I think it was North Carolina or South Carolina,
some states,
h w w were really bad with it.
They would catch people that would be say like,
say if you were going to buy a car,
like you call the guy on the phone how much you want for the car?
10 grand.
Okay,
I got it.
So you've got your 10 grand,
your cash and driving over this guy's house to buy the car and you have this 10
grand,
you get pulled over the cop go,
what are you doing?
10 Grand?
I'm going to buy a car.
Well,
we don't believe you were going to take that 10 grand.
And so they would take that 10 grant.
In one case,
this police department had bought a Margarita machine with a 10 grand that they
stole from people that they thought were buying drugs.
So they claim to think we're to think,
but just stop and think about that.
They took the Margarita machine by a drug machine,
which is what a Margarita machine is.
I mean a Margarita mixer.
Like what the fuck man?
Like that kind of corruption,
that kind of sneakiness where you write it down and you make it legal quotes.
Well it's on the books search,
you know,
acid asset forfeiture be a,
for people that are suspicious or suspected for selling drugs.
If you have more than x amount of dollars on you,
we can pull you over for that.
And they've just used that over and over again,
that one law to rip off law abiding citizens and then drag them through the
legal system for years at their own expense.
So even if they get their money back,
the amount of time it's cost them.
And you know,
obviously that time a lot of it is you're going to lose work because of that
time and then hiring lawyers,
legal fees
and if you lose,
they just,
they robbed you of time and the money.
If you can't prove where that money came from,
like maybe you're just really shitty with your taxes,
you don't pay taxes,
you work for cash and you've been just like working odd jobs for cash is she
saved up a bunch of money.
You can't,
you can't prove that that money came from illegal means you're fucked.
Well,
like everything else in this country,
it's set up to fuck the person who can't afford to defend them and set up even a
creepier way.
That's anti the way this country's supposed to be set up where you're guilty
until proven innocent.
You have to prove yourself innocent,
right?
Just by having currency on you,
I mean,
and it's less than someone makes in a year.
It's like the idea that you had savings,
get the fuck outta here.
You don't save anything dummy and see that and some kid who's selling weed and
live in his parent's basement.
If they bust him,
they take the parents' house.
Parents had nothing to do with it.
They'll take your car,
they pull you over and you got a joint in your car.
They sell your car.
I mean,
there's been a lot of that going on over the past few decades.
Ever since that just say no shit.
When we saw on television with Nancy Reagan that that began the fucking hysteria
of this stuff.
And then asset forfeitures just legalized stealing and it's a,
you know,
a fucking billion dollar industry in this country.
Yeah.
Legalized stealing and then you've got legalized.
Um,
you know,
a bribery in the political system.
That's what lobbyists are.
Those trucks.
Yeah,
super pacs.
I mean,
the whole of the whole,
this country is collapsing right eye.
You can see it.
If you start reading these books we're talking about,
you can see the phase that we're in.
We're in a phase now where there are all these different industries that are set
up to extract the Commonwealth.
Like literally the wealth of the community is being pulled in a war.
The wars in the Middle East.
What was that serving?
The only people who benefited from any of that were,
you know,
Bechtel and Raytheon and Halliburton.
Yeah.
These guys who do this for a living and Eisenhower himself said,
you know the military industrial complex,
when you get people who make a living with bombs and they need to be making
bombs,
well they're going to blow those bombs up.
They got to find a reason to use those box cars.
That was one of the creepiest speeches ever and the most fascinating thing about
it is that it was captured.
I mean it was,
it was broadcast on television,
but if you didn't listen to at that time it was gone.
He said it and then it was gone and it was years and years and years later
before people started actually watching that,
like in the fog of war.
It wasn't in the fog of war was in that is that the,
the McNamara movies might not have been in that but,
but regardless,
it's definitely available on Youtube.
I mean I've watched it a dozen in the corporation.
Have you seen that film?
That's a great doctor.
Very good documentary.
That's a creepy documentary when you realize that when they compare
corporations,
psychopaths,
and the idea of the infinite growth paradigm,
it is constantly making new.
Like if you make
$1 billion a year,
you go,
wow,
you're successful.
What do you make next year?
Well,
I'm just going to make a billion again.
What are you a fucking loser?
You have to make 1,000,000,001 billion to infinite growth.
Like that is what the stock market's all about,
right?
Yeah.
Consistent,
infinite growth.
Apple consistently makes more money every year.
They have to make more money at Google every year.
Every fucking company they have to make more money.
You can't,
Chris Ryan enterprises is,
you have to constantly be in the Black Chris Ryan,
bad news for my shareholders.
We peaked.
We decided to convert our dollars to whatever the fuck they have in Spain.
What's the Spain money?
Oh,
they're in euro's now.
Used to be pacet those.
So what do you do when you go over there?
I still back.
I left my fucking wife work.
I married a doctor.
Dude,
I thought I married a doctor.
I'm like,
I am sad.
I am set for life.
And that's how you were thinking when you married her.
Well you know a little bit while you love her obviously of course I love there's
also that added benefit.
The fact that she's in a good business.
Well I,
I mean the thing is doctors in Europe don't make the kind of money doctors
making the u s right,
but nor do they,
you know,
go out,
come out of college with 200 grand in debt.
Right.
So practice insurance,
is that all it's burden?
No,
I mean the whole thing is so amped up in the u s good doctor.
Like you know,
normal sort of,
she's a psychiatrist.
The psychiatrist in Spain,
you know,
good experience,
whatever might make 70 grand a year,
something like that.
You know,
like a decent stable,
you know,
good benefits.
Everyone in Spain,
everyone in Europe gets at least a month off every year.
That's cool.
Paid a month.
If you work in a shop,
you get a month off you,
whatever.
But they have the full 30 days off.
Or do they get like a week here,
a whole 30 days.
Use it when you want three days in a row.
Most you can do if you want.
Most people take August the month of August.
Like nothing is happening in Barcelona is empty really in the month of August.
Yeah,
it's,
it's amazing.
Um,
but you know,
like the,
the thing about Spain that I love is that life is about pleasure.
I mean,
if we had to really boil it down,
there is no shame in pleasure and in America.
Pleasure is shameful.
Why do you think that is?
Is why we say it goes back to the puritans,
the original sort of influence with the puritans and that it got amped up.
You know,
like we're talking about the war on drugs and we were talking about the Cobra
factory and these unintended consequences.
If you look,
it's serve political ends to keep attacking outsiders who did have pleasure,
black Indians,
uh,
Mexicans,
you know,
they're coming back again into fashion is the victims,
attack these brown skinned a pleasure,
pleasure.
You know,
he didn't just cause they're,
they're evil.
They're,
that's all evil shit with their
dance.
Nobody buys that shit in Europe.
Footloose fain anyway.
Yeah.
Fucking flipped Lewis.
This is how dumb we are in America.
We made footloose again,
they tried to remake footloose box.
That's interesting though.
It's also when you look at it,
America is so overwhelmingly infatuated with productivity.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean being productive and getting agency.
Yes.
Sufficiency.
Yeah.
And you know,
look at our workforce,
you know,
will like there's a God damn commercial.
I think it's for like Shell.
I think it's,
I think it's a shell commercial and there's a an old band and it's a weirdest
fucking commercial and it's,
it's talking about how hard this guy works and this guy,
he's a farmer and he's like standing like a field of wheat and he's like,
you work hard.
Not because you have to,
but because it's what you do.
And the guy smiles and I'm like,
what the fuck are you saying?
It's almost like you're trying to trick people into working hard so they can
tell people there it is.
Right the most.
This is the guy.
Can we play this?
This is play this cause it's just go full screen because it's so fucking
bizarre.
This is one of the weirdest commercials,
man.
I always weird out.
Can I,
cause they ere this commercial during hunting shows?
No,
because you have to
know because some boss
that,
because that's what you were born to do.
Now watch this.
They get close on.
This guy serves the best we can do a smiles.
It's what you're born to do.
Thank you.
Thank you for working hard from the number one heavy duty engine oil and
America.
What the fuck?
Kind of a commercial is that it's what you were born to do.
Now here's what kills me.
The person who wrote those words doesn't work for Shell.
He works for an advertising agency that they hired to do that.
Yeah,
that old man.
He's a fucking actor.
Yes.
Uh,
nobody who works for Shell really had anything to do with that.
You know?
So the,
the classic commercial,
we here at Chevron,
we believe that when I read Blah,
and then you see all the people with clipboards and hardhats and various racial
backgrounds.
None of those people work for fucking Chevron.
He wrote the words doesn't work.
The guy who was reading the words,
it doesn't worry.
There is no,
Chevron is like a is an entity that's,
there is no there,
there is a collection of people designed to collect money and it's not even the
people who matter because the,
all of those people could quit tomorrow and Chevron would still exist.
They just hire more people.
So Chevron's like the whirlpool and the people are the water.
Oh you know that's so that's part of this whole thing I'm writing.
But did you see that commercial?
Speaking of irritating American commercials,
there was one,
I think it was on the Superbowl even where there's like a dude walking through
house
and he's like,
why do I have the best I have the best cause that's what I am.
And that's what I do.
And he like high fives.
His kid,
it was a Cadillac commercial under that.
He'd seen it.
Oh it was so fucking annoying.
Why do I have the best cause that's what I said too.
I am,
we work harder.
We play harder.
W and it's about America row.
What happened to bro,
bro used to be cool.
You know that goes in a frat.
I know,
but calling someone bro used to be what's up bro.
He used to be okay.
He used to be like a black thing.
In fact,
it started out with white people ruined it.
It's like white guys ruined bro.
What's up bro?
Like that used to be okay [inaudible] be like,
he called me Bro.
I'm a brother.
It's short for brother.
But now bro is like a douchey his thing,
someone could call you,
he's up in a row or one of the things that people love to throw around is,
especially in the fitness industry is bro Science.
It's like when like there's a lot of like really wacky ideas when it comes to
athletics and uh,
some,
some people they have these ideas that don't necessarily have any scientific
background to them and they call it bro Science.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's full of Bro Science bromance.
Yeah Bro.
Man.
But bromance is,
you know,
you love a guy.
Like that's like,
oh,
that guy's awesome.
I got a bromance with that guy.
And there's like,
not as quite as there's like this,
someone was teaching me the,
what is it?
The hand shake shoulder one arm.
There is a definite thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's like a grip,
like a fucking manly thumb up grip and then the,
the one thing,
and if you're really,
do she give a couple slaps on the back?
The,
yeah.
There's a word for that too,
that like,
I'm not gay slapped.
I've seen people slap each other pretty goddamn hard doing that.
That doesn't feel good.
Here's another thing I love about Spain.
You kiss girls always on the mouth when you know,
when on the cheeks when you meet,
uh,
you meet a woman,
you kiss,
kiss a,
okay.
Then I come to America and it's like,
hi,
how are you?
You know,
like keep four feet away from him.
He might be a rapist.
Your I raping them already.
What are you doing looking at them?
You fucking create you over 50,
50 looking at a woman.
Shit,
fuck is wrong with you.
Don't you have grandchildren or something that's going wait on.
Hey,
what do you think about about Donald Trump?
Talking about how hot his daughter is?
Did he say that he did?
Oh,
you didn't hear about this became a big problem because he said,
uh,
he said,
you know,
Ivanka,
my daughter,
she's one of the hottest,
most beautiful women alive.
And he said,
I'll tell you what if I were 30 years younger and not her dad,
Whoa,
what the fuck does that mean?
Jesus Christ?
I wonder if he's jerked off to his daughter just saying,
look,
this is just
thought no one's getting hurt here.
Me alone in my idea,
I made her.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's a weird thing to say is a weird thing to say,
but I think it's better to say it than to think it and give it power.
Right,
right.
I think saying shit,
and this again,
you know,
back to the whole Spain us thing,
uh,
in America there is a thought crime and in Spanish,
I don't think,
you know,
maybe I'm romanticizing span.
I lived there a long time.
But another thing I really like about living in Spain is that I,
I speak the language well enough to like,
if I'm paying attention,
I know what everyone's saying,
but if I'm not paying attention,
it all just becomes Ruben.
I'm born,
I'm blue in the background.
Oh,
nice.
Like jazz.
Yeah.
It's sort of let her be kind of elevator music.
When I was in high school,
there was a,
someone wrote a paper for the,
the,
an article for the local school paper.
And um,
you know,
I don't remember most things from high school so long ago,
but I remember this one article that this kid wrote about what they make you do
in the boy scouts,
and it was about the tenants of the boy scouts,
whatever they were.
But one of them was about keeping your thoughts pure.
Oh yeah.
And he wrote something that was really cool.
It wasn't,
you know,
obviously really smart kid.
I wish I remember who it was,
but he wrote,
well,
why do I have to keep my thoughts pure?
He goes,
one of the things that I like about my thoughts so that they're mine there.
I can think whatever I want,
as long as I don't do anything that harms anybody.
Why do you care what my thoughts are?
And I remember reading that and I was like,
wow,
that's so right.
Like what?
What does that mean?
Keep your thoughts?
Pure guy's in jail now,
probably.
Yeah,
he might be.
He might be just a,
George Carlin did a great thing on that,
you know,
in terms of Catholicism and how he said like,
this was like class clown way back,
right?
Yeah.
I remember I was a little kid.
My Dad got that record and I remember the one of the bits in there was like,
you know,
in Catholicism,
if you think about sitting,
you've already sent.
So you're thinking about feeling up Sally at the weekend,
save your time.
You're,
you're already your sin.
It's done right.
And pure thoughts,
impure thoughts that straight out of Christianity.
Well,
the also the confession,
it confessionals one of the most bizarre and ridiculous,
but his balls on the table,
any religious it.
And it was invented to make sure that people weren't doing anything wrong.
I mean,
the,
the priests would immediately report to any higher ups have any illegal activity
or stealing or you know,
adultery or fornication or whatever the fuck it would be.
[inaudible] about the crazy shit where people were fucking animals in the middle
ages and they would have trials and sometimes the animals would be executed for
being overly seductive.
You know what?
Now that you brought this up,
I read something recently about this,
God,
I can't remember what the story was,
but it was the animal trials.
It was about,
and we'll try,
they might've been like batteries could be,
I dunno.
I have a friend who just wrote a book,
the boundaries of desire.
Uh,
he's a historian who focuses on,
um,
sexuality.
And,
uh,
his first book was sex and punishment and it was sort of like from the origins
of civilization to the end of the 19th century.
And then boundaries of desires,
the 20th century.
So he writes about all this crazy legal shit and you know,
like the Comstock laws that made it illegal to,
to,
um,
in early 20th century America to,
uh,
to even teach sex education to women.
Like you couldn't even teach women how they get pregnant.
That was a legal cause of this crazy fun.
Wow.
I've always wondered what it is about people that makes them like,
it's oftentimes like some of the earliest imprinting with pleasure that makes
people attracted to certain things.
This is where like fetish has come from.
And I've always wondered like,
like some people are like,
just overly attracted to extremely overweight women.
Like for whatever reason that just locks in to them.
That's their thing.
And I've always wondered like,
what is it about sexuality that like sexuality is like malleable.
Like you can kind of,
it kind of adjusts to like what your earliest impressions of like I've heard
stories of guys who,
uh,
caught their mom putting on pantyhose wants when they were like really young and
then for the rest of their life became like fascinated with a fetish of women
wearing panty hose and like don't want to jerk off on pantyhose and have
pantyhose rubbed on their dicks and it becomes this weird sort of a sexual
imprinting thing.
Right?
Yeah.
One of the interesting differences between male and female sexual development is
that women don't seem to have that women appear,
it's called erotic plasticity.
Women are plastic throughout their lives,
so it's easier for them to adapt to different situations.
Now sometimes that works against them,
right?
Because they fall in love with an asshole and abusive asshole or whatever.
But um,
men have a developmental window generally from like five to nine years of age,
somewhere in there.
And it's exactly as you described it,
if there's a particular experience that they have during that time,
it can resonate with them for the rest of their lives.
And once that window closes,
that's it.
It's done.
So,
you know,
as you say,
it could be pantyhose,
it could be red,
high heels,
it could be,
you know,
whatever it is.
They've got that association and they can never not have it.
They'll have it for the rest of their lives.
Some people argue that pedophilia is a result of this same sort of thing.
And I've argued not in writing,
but I've,
I've mentioned it on the podcast.
I think that there's a form,
a manifestation of homosexuality of what we call homosexuality,
which is really a fetish,
um,
is more,
is better described as a fetish experienced by a straight man.
And all right,
I'll tell you what I mean by that.
Let's say you,
you're born straight.
There's,
there's definitely a genetic component to sexual orientation,
right?
It's getting back to where we started.
Like how much is genetic,
how much is experiment experiential?
So just as a seven year old boy can have an experience with,
you know,
seeing someone with pantyhose or,
whatever.
He's under the table and his mom's friend comes and she's got red high heeled
shoes and he's got a hard on.
And so he associates the two.
What if that seven year old boy has an experience with another boy or within a
man or an adolescent or whatever.
Right?
So he,
this guy sucks his dick or whatever it is.
And so he's got this very deep association between have,
you know,
having a man sucking his dick and this incredible pleasure,
even though he's straight,
he's got that association.
So for the rest of his life,
he could have that association in the same way that another boy has the
association with pantyhose or high heeled shoes or whatever.
It's a fetish.
It's not his orientation.
So then what you've got is a straight guy who has a fetish for getting a blow
job from a man.
So every once in a while he goes down to the truck stop and you know,
has this experience,
he gets caught.
Everyone says,
oh,
you're a closeted gay man.
And He's thinking,
I don't think I am,
but I don't know what the fuck I am.
All I know is I love my wife.
I have sex with my wife.
I idea I'm not,
I could never fall in love with a man.
I never think about having a relationship with a man.
But man,
I love it when this guy with a mustache sucks my dick.
So I,
I've never really wanted to write about this.
And the reason is that I think it could play into the hands of the Christians
who are arguing that you can pray the gay away.
Yeah.
You see what I mean?
Because in a case like that,
I think there could be a therapeutic,
um,
uh,
solutions,
well solution or,
or just a re a therapeutic treatment that could have some value.
Um,
but I mean,
in my case,
I would never say that there's a sickness there.
I would just say it's a fetish.
Like some people are into latex.
You're into that,
you know,
totally makes sense.
I mean,
it's,
there are weird things that people get sort of bonded to their sexuality gets
bonded to always men,
almost never women.
You'll never find a woman who can't come,
you know,
if she's not sniffing latex.
But something about rubber.
I have a friend who's a dominatrix or not.
She's more than it.
I mean,
she's a humiliate tricks.
Humiliate,
humiliate tricks.
So she's the next level.
She specializes in dudes who get off on being humiliated.
And I had her on the podcast.
Uh,
she's,
she's really smart,
really interesting.
And it's not her thing.
She just stumbled into this.
So it's just a business for her.
It's a business.
She's like Shell oil,
Dick Slapping.
We hear it humiliate tricks.
We Suck Dick.
Not because we want to.
Oh,
because what we're,
which she never meets the dude's.
It's all internet.
One on,
one of the best things about it is she's got phone lines dedicated to guys who
get off on being ignored.
So the phone rings,
she picks it up.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
Puts the phone down and goes about her day.
And it's like,
yeah,
guys who get off on being ignored by the Greek to be ignored by a professional.
Ignore.
She sells her socks,
her panties,
her old tennis shoes,
her toenail clippings,
her hair,
her salon.
She,
the way she got into it was she's living in Japan and she was like 17 or
something and she was a corresponding with some guy online and like he was
trying to pick her up and she wasn't into it,
but he was funny.
So she corresponded with them.
And at one point he said,
she said,
I gotta go take a Piss.
And he said,
Oh,
don't throw it away.
Put it in a bottle.
I'll buy it from you.
She's like,
come on,
do you're full of shit.
And he's like,
no,
seriously,
trust me,
I will.
I'll styles,
you know,
200 bucks or whatever.
So she puts it,
she pisses in a bottle and she sends it and there's 200 bucks shows up in her
account.
She's like,
wow,
this is interesting.
There must be more guys like this out there.
So she starts,
you know,
investigating it and she finds that the world is full of these dudes.
Seriously check her out.
Sierra Lynch.
It's like,
all right,
I'm going to write her name,
check out her site.
She's beautiful.
Does she live?
She lives in Portland and see it,
but she spells it c e a r a Sierra Lynch.
Um,
and yeah,
she's got guys,
but she's been on a,
she was on a show on a,
yeah,
HBO recently show that as some sex show.
I was on it too.
Um,
she's been profiled.
She's,
you know,
she's a public figure.
That's hilarious.
Dunkin used to know a girl who would do,
she is Dunkin used to know a girl humiliate tricks.
Xtrordinair congratulations young lady.
You found an excellent niche or niche as it were.
Um,
Duncan knew a girl who would sell her socks and a,
she would wear them for days at a time to get them like really stinking and then
she would sell them to dudes and you know,
like a couple hundred bucks at a time.
So like that was her thing.
She's just be wearing socks all the time and then sending them to people.
It's a good gig.
Gas Getting paid for doing what you're doing anyway,
I guess.
I don't know.
There's just something weird about the idea of being connected to these people
that are so fucked up.
They want your stinky socks.
Yeah.
Although as you know,
as things go,
I mean,
getting back to fetishize,
you know,
it's a relatively harmless,
harmless thing,
you know,
and the fact that now people can engage these things in a more or less open way.
I mean,
what worries me with her is she,
she was telling me like,
there are guys who really get off on being blackmailed.
So these guys would give her like all their bank account numbers,
passwords,
and then they would send her photos of like,
you know,
like me with a dildo up my ass.
And now her job is to threaten to tell the wife,
uh,
you know,
I'm going to tell your wife if you don't like,
give me $500 and oh no,
please don't tell my wife and you got to go through this whole thing.
And I mean,
it's kind of crazy,
you know?
And I said to her like,
you know,
well,
and she said like,
I'd never,
you know,
I don't contact wives because they haven't agreed to participate in this.
I'm not going to do that.
Well that's very ethical of her.
Oh,
she's,
she has to be at professional.
She's a pro.
Uh,
but I said to her,
well,
like,
what about the banking on?
She's like,
no,
I would never,
you know,
I don't,
that would be a crime.
Even if the guy gave it to me.
And I said,
yeah,
but what if your email gets hacked?
And she was like,
oh,
I hadn't thought of that.
Yeah.
Some Russian kid that email.
That's a lot of stuff there.
Wow.
That's an interesting thing.
Well,
maybe the guy's a separate humiliation bank account.
I hope so.
I,
yeah,
I mean,
God,
but to get to real rush,
you'd have to give her your real bank account to get the real full.
Like,
fuck,
I could be ruining my life.
I know another woman who specializes in kicking dudes in the balls.
I've seen that.
I've seen girls step on them.
It was like step on guys balls like the high heel shoes,
stomp on them.
You could lose a ball like that by the way.
Super easy.
Yeah,
I would think so.
Oh God.
It's so terrifying.
I'm so boring.
I mean,
I spent time with all these like really kinky people,
but like
basic,
you know,
well you're not fucked up.
Sorry.
But it's,
it goes back to what we're saying about people being sexually malleable.
Like what do you think that is?
Is it because people couldn't have like a very rigid or men rather couldn't have
a rigid idea of what sexually attractive because it's,
they did,
if their standards are too high,
then they wouldn't reproduce.
And so in the times of demanding,
you know what,
we're like
John Marco grow,
uh,
who is one of the,
um,
uh,
lead scholars that was discipling the Dead Sea Scrolls.
He wrote this book called the Sacred Mushroom and the cross.
And it was,
yeah,
it's,
it's great book and a,
it was bought up by the Catholic Church actually.
And the [inaudible] only find it in a [inaudible] for a while.
You could only find it in,
um,
used form,
but now a young urban is a republished it and you can,
you can get it again.
Uh,
and he wrote another one called the Christian,
your sacred mushroom and the Christian sacred mushroom in the cross and
something Dead Sea Scrolls in the Christian myth.
And it's essentially about,
uh,
that what the,
it's his after studying the Dead Sea Scrolls for 14 years.
It's his interpretation that what the,
what Christianity was really all about was the consumption of psychedelic
mushrooms and fertility cults.
And that fertility back then was extremely important.
It's extremely important to breed because we didn't have this luxury that we
have today of like people say,
oh,
he's your girl on the pill,
man,
I got her pregnant.
Fuck,
what do I do?
Like people wanting to get people pregnant because the human population was not
guaranteed.
Like there was a very real possibility that you would come into a village that
was empty because everybody died.
They died of play or they were invaded or whatever the fuck it was.
Like they didn't have enough people.
And now there's no one.
And your name doesn't pass on so that this was like a real possibility.
So people is the idea of being sexually mallow malleable that people can adapt
to almost anything to become attracted,
to just make sure that they are attracted to something,
that they can come in something and make a person,
whether it's overweight women or skinny women or this or that,
that it can move around and that occasionally it gets imprinted.
That this is like the thing that you're really into and that in times of great
excess when people are Slovenly and like,
like today,
like,
you know,
you like this idea that [inaudible] guy gets a fetish off being blackmailed.
Like what is that?
That's a guy with too much fucking free time.
Clearly much money,
too much money,
too much free time.
He's not starving to death.
That's not a guy who was out there picking mushrooms trying to find something
edible to eat.
You know,
this is a guide.
It's like sitting around trying to figure out way to occupy his fucked up mind
because you know,
it's too easy to just live like he doesn't have real survival concern.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well we've eroticized power,
which,
which ties into that.
Um,
uh,
I've read that,
one,
one source of clientele for a lot of these sorts of women is Muslim dudes who
want to be forced to eat pork.
They get an erotic charge from that.
Makes Sense.
It makes sense.
Right?
Yeah,
makes sense.
I mean,
I often think like,
you know,
getting back to like my boring sexuality,
I think part of the reason that I'm not kinky is that I'm not repressed.
Right.
You know,
and in a way it's like,
it's like a steam engine.
If you don't have that container and build up the pressure,
you don't get that explosive release.
So if you're just kind of like,
yeah,
whatever,
you know,
I get laid sometimes and I like women and yeah,
like it's great,
but it's,
I mean,
I wonder if healthy is less exciting than crazy.
Well,
he's crazy exciting to you though because crazy is not exciting to me.
I don't fight like the humiliate humiliate tricks.
I absolutely believe her.
I believe that she has like a series of guys that wanted to shit in their face,
whatever the hell it is.
But to me it's silly.
I don't get it.
Like,
you know,
what are those guys having stronger orgasms than you and me.
It could be by me
costs.
Yeah,
that's it.
Get it.
They steal your bank account is shut in your face and you just of like a fucking
maybe.
What do mean is that that fucking brief experience of coming,
you know?
I mean how much it would all you have to do if you want to come really hard,
it's just not come for awhile.
Right?
You don't really need to have,
so it kick you in the balls or shit in your hair,
like things you can do.
All you have to do is just like go without water.
Tastes amazing when you haven't had any water for awhile.
And it's true though,
when you haven't had water for a while,
God,
it's the greatest thing in the world.
But when you have it all the time,
it becomes normal and you don't even want it.
You want a diet coke.
Yeah.
But if you were starving or dying of thirst,
rather you,
you would just love to get that water in your mouth.
And I think that's kind of the same thing with sex.
And that's where I think a lot of perverts fucked themselves over cause they're
just jacking off all day till they get blisters on their Dick and then they have
to find a new way to hold their Dick where it doesn't hurt as much.
And you,
when you do come,
it's,
you're chasing the dragon.
Like it doesn't feel good anymore.
But if you could just take a few weeks off,
you would be so horny that when you did come it,
your ears would rang.
You'd be like,
Whoa,
but you can't,
you can't hold off.
And if he,
if you hold off long enough,
then you get to the promised land.
Which wet dreams.
Oh yeah,
I can get those after three days.
Seriously,
three days of no sex man.
Your testosterone levels must be through the roof in their day.
Yeah,
I've make sure that through the roof I add it.
Oh I should probably try that now that I help.
I'm a creep.
Once you reach creep age,
what you need is t well people do,
you know that's a,
it's like a source of shame for some people.
They don't want to admit that
stastrom replacement therapies,
like a shameful thing.
Like people have asked me and then I told them,
I go,
yeah,
I take testosterone and they go like,
what?
I'm like,
could you just tell peaches admitting yet like,
look,
it's,
it's a chemical component of your body.
It's like if your body was lacking in blood and you can just simply add blood to
it,
you feel better wouldn't,
wouldn't you do that?
Yeah.
But for whatever reason,
testosterone is associated with being a man.
I also have a Hypo thyroidism.
It's a,
it's called Hashimoto's disease.
It's a genetic,
my mom has it and other people in my family habit,
so I take the stuff called Armour thyroid.
That is a,
it's formulated from pigs thyroid and it's great.
It makes me feel way better.
But I was having some real problems before I was taking,
I get these crazy headaches at night,
like my head was pounding or I thought,
I thought it was something really wrong with me and I would fall asleep.
Like when I would fall asleep,
it was like I got shot with a tranquilizer dart.
Like at the end of the day I was just so wiped out.
I couldn't figure out what it was.
And uh,
so,
uh,
while I was on fear factor,
um,
I had some real issue with it.
Like I'm fucking,
headaches would be crazy.
I was be so tired at the end of the day and then I got my blood test done.
But I tell people that I take thyroid medication and nobody would bat an eye
like,
Oh,
you replaced your thyroid hormone.
Well that's logical,
but you tell people that you replace your testosterone and they're like,
well,
what the fuck are you doing that do you have to know?
I definitely don't have to.
If I take it off,
if I stopped doing it,
I will have less testosterone than I have now,
but I won't feel as good.
Is that simple?
It's up to you to not abuse it though,
because if you abuse it,
like there are guys,
like especially at some MMA fighters if like tested like these hyper human
levels that are not even safe.
Like they're really actually kind of dangerous,
right?
Because the idea is that more is better and just keep going harder and harder.
But you really shouldn't do that because then you could develop anxiety.
There's a lot of different things that happened when you do it like rage and
stuff,
you can definitely get rage.
You,
um,
you definitely get more upset at things more easily.
But a lot of people,
they develop actual anxiety.
Like you,
you have a anxiety attacks from having,
uh,
an excess of testosterone.
Start getting paranoid and you can get weirded out about things.
It's just a matter of going to an ethical doctor that really understands what
they're doing and then make sure you're,
you're not taking too much of it.
You're doing it right.
And you just want to stay within like a healthy,
consistent standard and you'll just feel better.
Your immune system will function better,
but people don't like to talk about it because it,
it it like you have to admit that somehow or another you needed that.
You have to admit that you're aging.
You don't have to write shameful again.
It's amazing.
They also,
and you're taking it not to like,
you know,
combat a disease.
You're taking it to feel better,
which is pleasure,
which is shameful,
shameful pleasure during pleasure.
You want to feel good all the time.
Well,
that's my issue with marijuana too.
You know,
I tell people like people that,
why do you need pot?
It's not that I need it.
I enjoy it,
I enjoy it and it gives me more pleasure.
It gives me more pleasure when I watch movies,
it gives me more pleasure when I eat food and it gives me way more pleasure when
I have sex.
It's sex feels way better when you take marijuana,
but that's an embarrassing thing to admit for some people,
whatever,
for whatever reason,
I love how the word needs comes in.
Why do you need it,
bro?
I don't need weed to have fun.
Who the fuck said anyone needed anything here?
You know,
I don't even need toothpaste.
Moralistic,
don't use toothpaste.
My teeth will be less clean,
but you know,
I don't need it.
It's a weird,
we were weird,
man.
We're weird.
And also that we don't want it.
We don't want to factor in our own mortality.
We don't want to address it.
We don't not want to admit it.
So anything that you're doing to mitigate that is a weakness.
Anything you're doing to combat anti aging is just vanity,
you know,
like,
well I guarantee you I have more energy because of it.
Again,
I know I do.
I know I feel better.
I can get done,
I can get more things done and my body works more efficiently,
especially someone like me that enjoys doing things that are physically active,
like martial arts,
Jujitsu,
like without the testosterone,
without growth hormone and thyroid hormone and all these different hormones that
are functioning at their optimum levels.
Your body's just not gonna work as well.
It's like having a race car that you don't take care of the spark plugs.
You don't,
you don't,
you know,
you don't replace the oil.
He just let it drive it until that fucking engine seizes up and then you're
done.
That's nature.
But if we need that,
but that's not nature because why are we getting vaccinated then you know,
why are we taking vitamins then?
Why am I going to the doctor and getting checkups?
Why don't I just like cancer?
Eat My body?
Why get chemo?
Why?
You know,
it's just natural.
Like we have weird ideas of what you should and all those weird ideas or not
based on critical thinking and objective analysis.
They're just based on the standards at somehow or another.
Someone else has set forth Chevron.
So you were born to work hard because you were born to you.
I mean,
you get a same thing with like these sex pills.
Like now the female Viagra and stuff.
It's bad.
It's bad shit.
Yeah.
Well it doesn't work either because of what we're saying.
No,
because the,
because of where we were talking about earlier,
the plasticity that women,
women's sexuality isn't about blood flow,
right?
Men,
if you make your Dick hard,
you're horny because in,
in engages nerve endings and you know,
like my Dick's hard,
I gotta fuck something,
you know.
Well,
even when guys get like a pea boner,
like when guys like get,
like if women don't know this,
when men have to urinate and your wake up in the middle of the morning and your,
your Dick is hard,
it's not because you're horny a lot of the times it's because you have to pay
this morning wood.
Yeah.
And that's what morning wood is.
But you can use that morning wood like you could use like any,
any regular old boner.
So when a guy wakes up and he has a boner and he did a lot,
oftentimes it's like,
well I don't want to waste that.
You know,
it becomes like a hammer that looks like a nail because like this looks like a
thing to use right here.
Excellent.
Will you,
you have a on average three erections per night if you sleep
eight hours.
Really?
So while you're sleeping you're getting boners.
Yeah.
And that's one of the ways they test to see if you're a impotence is
psychological or physiological.
They'll put like a little piece of paper tape,
uh,
on your,
on your Dick and in the morning if the tape is torn,
it means you had an erection at night.
So it means your body,
your blood flow is fine.
It's a head thing.
Wow.
Weird.
You have to tie a ribbon around your Dick Tie Ribbon Round Sarah in the middle
of the night for the hostages.
How strange.
What a strange thing.
Sex is weird.
I mean you,
you,
you asked a question earlier,
uh,
about the,
you know,
what's the purpose of the fetish generation,
module in the male brain and all that.
And I was thinking,
well two things.
Um,
one in sex at dawn,
we talked about animals cause this appears to be not only a human thing but
common to male mammals as well of other species.
Um,
there was one experiment where this guy,
I think he was in Scotland,
took all the,
he had a herd of sheep and a herd of goats,
and when year he took all the babies and he put them with the other species.
So now all the baby goats are living with the sheep and all the baby sheep are
living with the goats.
And he let them live with that species until they reach sexual maturity.
At which point they were having sex with the,
so the goats are having sex with the sheep and the sheep were having sex with a
goat story.
Then he takes them and puts them back with their own species.
Okay.
And what happened was the females were like,
all right,
whatever.
And they were now,
so now the female sheep are having sex with the male sheep.
Right.
There were switched back,
but the males refused.
The males who came,
you know,
who had been raised with the other species are like,
no,
I'm a goat fucker.
Sorry.
Not Interested.
Because they had been imprinted.
Wow.
So the females just went with what was there.
The males were like,
no,
that's not me.
So that's really interesting.
Yeah,
that's really interesting.
And the testosterone,
and we also talked about that.
I remember there were some interviews with um,
a guy,
there was one that was a guy who had a disease where he's body suddenly stopped
making testosterone and he described,
you know,
eventually he was diagnosed and started taking supplements,
but he described it and he would,
and it was like all,
it wasn't about sex.
It was all pleasure stopped.
It was like,
I didn't give a shit about music.
I didn't give a shit about food.
I didn't give a shit about relationships.
I just was like blahzay about everything.
And then there was another one where we quoted a,
someone who's going through a sex change from female to male.
And she talked about like when she was a woman,
she was a lesbian and she lived in Manhattan and she was talking about like,
yeah,
you know,
I'd be on the subway and I'd see an attractive woman.
And I think,
Huh,
I wonder what she's like and what kind of food she's into and what she's
reading.
And there and then when she was transitioning to Male,
she started taking testosterone and she said,
once I started taking testosterone,
I'd be on the subway and I'd see the same kind of woman and I'd just be like,
tats
can't.
And
she said,
uh,
I,
it really gave me insight and compassion for adolescent boys.
Chaz Bono said that.
Oh really?
Yeah,
she said that when,
well he said that when he transitioned from being female to Male,
that he understands it now.
Yeah.
For the longest time,
like he never understood man and it was just alien to them.
And then once he started taking testosterone and you're like,
oh yeah,
this is why guys are so fucking creepy.
It's like they're just overwhelmed by this demon inside of the we call called
testosterone that you require in order to be happy and to enjoy anything in
life.
I was,
one of the things that happens to men with a traumatic brain injuries is the
pituitary gland gets damaged,
they stop producing testosterone,
they get deeply depressed.
And one of the best ways to mitigate that or supplementing them with
testosterone like that cure is a lot of the depression that a lot of these
soldiers go through when they come back from the war is traumatic.
Traumatic brain injury just disrupts the pituitaries uh,
ability to function.
You know,
one of the,
we,
when you sort of typical situation and get a guy like my dry mid fifties,
been married a long time,
monogamous typical midlife crisis has sex with his secretary and then suddenly
it's like Holy Shit,
you know,
I'm in love.
Right?
Why does he think he's in love?
Because food tastes better.
The colors are brighter,
everything's more interesting.
Why is that?
Because his testosterone levels have gone up.
One of the only things you can do without supplements to increase testosterone
is has sex with a new woman.
Your body responds to you having sex with a new woman with a spike in
testosterone production.
So he's got this t elevated t levels.
He thinks he's in love,
he's not in love.
He's just fucking someone new for the first time in 20 years.
So he divorces his wife.
Cause now he's in love with this woman who seems to have the keys to the fucking
universe that wears off in a couple of
it and now he's,
you know,
even more fucked than he was before.
Well,
that's also the key to this whole midlife crisis thing where guys buy sports
cars,
you know,
reports will also sports cars.
Like literally driving a sports car elevates your testosterone,
especially when you're quote unquote peacocking.
Especially if Jay Leno's driving and you're in the passenger seat,
that was as good episodes actually.
But when you're driving around people,
especially potential young mates,
females,
they could see you write,
your testosterone rises when you're in this car.
Right.
And even
talking and flirting with potential young girls that you may,
you know,
one day have sex with just being around them raises your testosterone.
Just the possibility.
Yeah.
Well,
I wonder,
getting back to Sierra,
I wonder if some of those guys who were buying her panties,
if they're not getting to start her own surges,
probably they're getting,
well,
something's happening,
right.
There's getting some kind of dopamine,
Serotonin,
some sort of a rush.
Yeah,
definitely.
Panties.
Oh,
hey,
have you ever heard of fecal transplants?
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean it sort of goes back to the,
we were talking about a biological thing really interesting.
Well,
it's fascinating how many things it cures and how many people have like real
thousand people die from a c difficile infestation every year.
And with fecal transplant,
98% recovery rate within hours.
Nuts.
It's crazy.
Then hours.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The biological organism,
the idea of the biological organism being an individual,
it's been completely debunked.
Like that's what probiotics are all about.
I'm a big fan of probiotics.
I drink,
whereas it,
and I'm bringing,
it must have left in my car.
I drink a Kombucha every day.
I drink that shit like water.
I drink two or three of them a day.
Well,
I'm a big fan.
I mean I spent a lot of my younger years traveling,
you know,
and in Central America and Asia and stuff.
And uh,
like when I'm in America,
I put on weight now part of it's that,
you know,
the food and I drink beer,
probably more beer.
The sir,
you know,
here you get a beer.
It's a pint.
Spain,
you get a beer,
it's about half a pint.
Real.
Yeah,
it's a cognac.
So again,
Spain,
it's just a different five servings of everything or smaller,
higher quality,
like really good and tasty but small.
So you're still allowed grass fed food too.
Like you know,
you don't get that corn fed fucking Monsanto,
Gmos,
you know,
that whole thing there.
They're kicked out of a lot of countries.
Um,
but yeah,
no in pesticides,
a friend of mine's in the wine importation business and he distributes,
um,
organic wines and he said he was in,
I don't know if it was Spain or France and he was like,
you know,
you guys should get organic certified,
we could charge more.
And they're like,
what are you talking about?
Like,
we would never put pesticides on our grapes,
you know,
like,
that's crazy.
Like we don't need to say it.
Like nobody would do that.
Right.
So it's a,
it's a very different culture.
But I think that the,
because the cheeses and the things are alive there can't import the ham even you
can't import Spanish.
Uh,
I guess now they've changed it.
You can start.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
food is alive.
So the microbiome,
the microbiome is very different.
Yeah.
I go to India,
I lose weight quickly.
Part of it's cause I have fucking dysentery.
Five is because you feel bad cause everybody else is starving.
Yeah.
There was an article recently about
a gray market foods in New York City and um,
I forget,
oh it was something I read online and a,
it might've been from dig,
see if you could find it on dig.
I think it is from dig.
That's where I get a lot of my um,
interesting news stories.
But um,
they were talking about this one particular type of cheese that is very
difficult to get and um,
it's,
it's cured with cheese mites like these,
these mites.
And if the Mites are of a certain number per cheese,
it becomes illegal to import into America.
Like,
it's like very sketchy,
like how you do it,
but over in France or wherever the fuck they grow,
this cheese where it's really popular,
it just gets fucking lousy with Mike and that,
that's where you get the real flavor of this cheese.
And it's like a nutty,
sort of a sweet taste to this cheese.
And a lot of it is attributed to the fact that,
first of all,
they don't use homogenizer.
Pasteurized milk is raw milk when they make their tunes,
which is the way the make the best cheese,
he keeps the enzymes in it and then they're not scared of all these funky
organisms.
Yeah.
This is it.
The gray market foods.
If you scroll down,
you'll see that cheese.
It's a sort of a like a orange looking weird fucking cheese.
That's it right there.
Oh yeah.
That stuff.
And if you,
uh,
make that a little larger so we can read it.
It's a,
it's looks really weird,
but this guy was talking about how good it tasted.
It's a,
the unique way they alter the aging process.
The presence of Mites.
FDA single does cheese out as a potential public health hazard.
How do you say it?
[inaudible]
has been banned and made it illegal for sale in the U and and digit indignant
consumers.
Staged protests.
Yeah,
it looks cool.
I like to try piece that.
I've definitely had that.
Yeah.
It's one of the things we did on fear factor to make things more disgusting was
we used really expensive cheese.
We mixed really expensive cheese in with some of the stuff to give it this
horrible fucking rotting smell and there's a expensive cheese,
what do they call it?
Cheese place.
There's a name for one of those places,
I don't know what's called,
but they had a cheese place in Beverly hills and so we used to send these people
that work for fear factor to Beverly hills is super expensive cheese place and
buy this really expensive,
hard to get cheese and it's stunk like death and we would pour that onto
whatever the fuck they had to eat and they would make them more,
more repulse.
Do you ever have like French people on now?
They'd be like,
Ooh,
la La.
Well,
Filipinos,
I have,
I've,
I've a bunch of friends that are Filipino and they would always be like,
as we serve people balut and Balut is a,
a a chicken or a duck embryo.
It's like the full little embryos in there and they'd eat the,
and they were like,
that's,
we love that.
Like get me a show.
You have heard of Anthony Bordain on the show?
On this?
Yeah.
That's cool.
I'd love to meet him sometime.
He's a great guy.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's an interesting character.
He'll anything.
Yeah.
Well he's um,
he's gotten like super into Jujitsu to the point where freight trains every day
with Hensville.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Every day.
Sometimes twice a day.
Yeah.
And his wife and his kid,
he's 58 years old.
He started at 58.
Now he's got,
he just earned his blue belt.
Oh,
it just started recently.
Yeah.
Like within a year ago.
Oh,
I thought there was a long term thing with,
no,
it's really recent.
Really.
Cause when I like risking getting hurt when you start something like that old,
well it depends on how you do it.
And it depends on who you do it with.
But absolutely.
You mean if you have bad training partners you can definitely get hurt,
but you can definitely get hurt.
Even with good training partners cause weird shit happens.
You know,
you roll over on an ankle,
you blow some tendons out and your knee,
you fuck up disc in your back.
It's all potential.
It's definitely not,
it's not fucking video games.
You know,
it's,
it's real life.
It's definitely dangerous.
Especially for a guy who's 58 who has no background of athleticism at all and
all of a sudden starts at a very advanced age and becomes completely obsessed
with it.
Yeah,
it's cool.
it is cool.
His original show that no reservation show really uh,
got me into the idea of food as an art form cause I just thought of food is
being,
well that's good foods.
Good.
This is good.
Right?
That place is good to eat at.
I didn't think of it as like,
oh,
this guy's making art that you taste like when,
so when you eat a great meal,
like that experience at central experiences,
the pleasurable experiences,
art,
it's like someone's art is giving you pleasure through your taste buds.
It's three smells.
And you know,
like when you have a really good meal,
you smell it,
you eat it.
Like there's an art to that.
I never really considered it that way until I watched his show.
And again,
that's a very European approach to food.
You know America food is fuel.
Yeah.
Shove that sandwich down your throat and get back to work.
Not In Spain,
man.
That's that.
Or France or Italy.
Yeah.
I have a buddy who's an athlete and he just,
he all,
he thinks about his food is fuel.
He goes,
I don't even care what it tastes like.
I just eat it.
He goes,
I'm just saying,
just want food is fuel.
And I'm like,
what soylent?
You heard about that?
Well,
soylent green or that movie,
they named it after that.
What is it?
It's these guys in Silicon Valley who are coding you,
right?
And they're like,
well,
I just want to work 24 hours.
I don't want to stop and eat.
It's a waste of time.
And so they came up,
they like developed this food source,
this Gorp that you just like squeeze out of a tube and it's got everything you
need and Oh,
one year I'll,
yeah.
Soylent
warrant.
So it's,
yeah,
you just like drink him.
Be Good for you though.
Look at that.
29 bucks a month and modular sweet protein that's going to make you grow to,
it's exactly the vitamins and minerals.
Yeah.
But what about,
yeah,
it's just weird.
Where's the pleasure?
There's no pleasure.
That's just nasty.
It's one
thing if you're a fucking astronaut,
you gotta survive in the space station,
which stuff you squirt in your mouth.
But this is like,
you have the abundance of the earth and you choose to squirt,
paste in your mouth instead.
We'll see.
Maybe this is part of,
you know,
this is this movement you were talking about,
right?
Because getting us to eat shit that doesn't take up space.
And we don't need clean air and we don't need healthy oceans.
You know,
that's two,
that's in the interest of the technology,
right?
If,
if,
if you see that that's where we're going,
if you think that that's where we're going,
then a lot of these things start to fall into place and make sense in a weird
way.
I mean,
I read the other day that the tuna stocks in the Pacific Ocean or down like 40%
in the last 20 years.
Incredible.
The stuff you receipt,
Jiro Dreams of Sushi.
You know what?
I've got it on.
Someone gave it to,
I haven't seen it,
but I resisted for a long time.
Can people kept telling me how bad it was.
I'm like,
whatever.
It's a fucking guy making Sushi who gives a shit.
But it's great.
It's really great.
And one of the things that they show in this movie is when he was young,
what,
what it would be like going to the fish market in Japan,
just fucking stacks of tuna and the tuna was so abundant.
And then the over fishing has made a massive impact on the,
on the fish supplies.
And we've literally,
I mean you look at how God damn big the ocean is the fact that we put a dent in
it at all.
It's just shocking.
More than a dent.
We're collapsing the shoulders of the fucking earth surface is lastic size of
Texas.
Fuck.
Cause I think it's even bigger than that.
Really?
Yeah.
And this kid has developed a,
I don't know if it's um,
it's an actual functional machine,
but he's developed some sort of advice to clean up the ocean Kimmer kind of
thing that suck the plastic out.
Well,
you got to think plastic once it becomes a valuable resource of someone figures
out how to take it out of the ocean.
If it was gold floating around out there,
we would have a million ships that are fighting over this to try to get in.
Like if Russia and the United States found gold,
gold particles circling around the billions and trillions of dollars worth,
boy,
they would,
couldn't wait to plant a flag in the middle of the ocean to suck all this gold
out of the water because it's plastic.
Or like I got plastic right here,
dude,
I don't need the ocean plastic.
Well that's why you need the government,
you know,
cause the government can create those artificial incentives.
Pay For cobras,
you know,
pay for plastic.
I think that uh,
that's the,
the government being a solution.
It's a beautiful idea but doesn't really work.
Yeah.
Well be nice if the government was completely altruistic and enlightened on the
balls of thing.
Okay.
Going back to,
we were talking about earlier,
if we had direct voting and direct taxation where you can say like,
okay,
I'm paying my taxes this year.
It's 20 grand.
I won five grand to go to education five grand to,
you know,
helping
poor people five grand or whatever,
blah,
blah.
Nothing to the military.
If you could actually,
or at least have some,
some way of registering what people want their money to go toward,
you know,
you'd have a much more responsive representative government
if they had an educated decision making process.
Yeah.
You really knew like,
well,
what kind of a threat are we under?
How much military do we really need?
Because if we don't need any military at all,
if there's no threat whatsoever,
well then that would be an appropriate way to respond.
But what if they couldn't tell us how much threat there really was and what if
people had this a idealistic idea of how the rest of the world functions,
but meanwhile,
there really is a need for the military.
Yeah.
I think the truth lies somewhere in the middle there.
I don't think that the world is this beautiful place that we need to not worry
about at all.
And then we don't need any military that just doesn't.
I watched those isis videos on youtube.
I just,
I'm not believe they're out there.
This be nasty.
There's a lot of people out there that are fucking crazy.
There's a lot of nutty fucking people that are killing people and would love to
kill more.
There's just always going to be that way.
And I think that like what we're talking about,
I think there's a,
there's a,
a push and a pull in this life.
And I think like,
you know,
we were talking about tides coming in and tides going out and population's
dropping and an increasing,
I think there's a need for resistance in some ways.
And I think that there's almost a need for bad things in order to inspire good
things.
Like we have to see the evil of something like isis or something,
you know,
fill in the blank,
a Joseph Kony,
the,
you know,
the Congo dictators and evil war lords.
We need to see things like,
you know,
EDI mean we need to see horrific things like Pol Pot.
We need to,
we need to be aware of that in order to almost promote the,
the opposite of it.
But what I would argue is that every one of those things that you mentioned is a
response to something earlier.
Like Pol Pot is a response to the Vietnam War and the destruction of Cambodia by
Nixon and Kissinger.
And you know,
um,
Coney is a response to the Congo having been exploited for ivory and then,
you know,
minerals within our phones.
And you know,
it's like every one of these things arises out of a colonial exploitation.
So,
you know,
we're saying,
Paul Potts,
evil,
well,
but pull pod is a response to evil that we're not often recognizes as evil
because it's coming from us coming from our side.
So I just feel like everybody who does something really nasty,
they think they're doing good.
You know what I mean?
Like those guys in Isis,
they think they're good.
Right?
They're doing it for a law.
Yeah.
Or they're doing it for,
you know,
in,
in revenge for the bombing
or,
right.
I mean,
it's this process.
So,
so I agree with you.
I mean,
I'm not,
I'm not an anarchist and I'm not crazy.
So I do feel like,
you know,
you've gotta be ready to fight to defend yourself.
But on the other hand it,
I sort of agree with,
you know,
the Gandhis and the Martin Luther King and that whole line civil disobedience,
the rose great essay that like the only way to really end violence is to just
not participate in it because the minute you participate in it,
then it's the cycle.
It's true.
Yeah.
It's unavoidable hands.
I mean that's sort of inarguable really.
Right.
But if you do not participate and your loved ones are slaughtered before your
eyes,
then what?
Like should you have acted to stop that from happening and is a certain amount
of violence did justified in order to promote a higher ethical and moral
standard for the culture to eliminate people who don't abide by those things.
But you would have to have very strict right interpretations of this and you'd
have to have very strict rules of engagement.
And we clearly don't have that.
Yeah.
And I wonder if we ever did it feels like it was better.
Right?
Doesn't it?
Like in talks talking about police in the u s like before the war on drugs,
it seems like cops were cool.
They weren't the enemy.
I thought that too.
But when you talk to cops,
like it seems like poverty and drugs and crime,
they're kind of always together.
Desperate.
There's a great documentary that I'm watching right now called,
I think it's called the seven five.
I'm Nick Depaulo told me about it.
He actually talked about on Arusha fears a podcast and then I went and got it.
Um,
what is it called?
It's called a,
yeah,
it's called the seven five.
And it's,
um,
it's all about this really corrupt precinct.
And I'm in New York City and,
uh,
the 19 I guess,
I think it's the 1970s,
but it's,
fuck,
that's it right there.
It's fucking incredible.
It's so God damn crazy.
This Guy Michael Dowd,
who I don't know his history,
I need to,
after the documentary is over,
I'm going to Google him and find out what his history was.
But he's hilarious.
He's out now,
I guess he's wearing civilian clothes is not a prisoner.
And he just,
he testified about all the corruption that he was involved in and you know,
all the shit that he was,
and then they,
they start reenacting it and talking about it in the documentary along with
facts and the different people in different players involved and like,
Whoa,
just completely out of control.
It's a totally out of control crime and corruption and drugs and you know,
so this is pre war on drugs is 1970s and it just,
I guess kind of pre war on drugs,
but Nixon sort of instituted a war on drugs and yeah,
they really instituted a war on drugs.
Uh,
essentially when they pass the sweeping psychedelic act of 1970 when they made
essentially everything psychoactive,
illegal,
all the different mushrooms and LSD and many people don't even know that.
But prior to 1970,
all that stuff was legal.
You,
there was one of the big issues with the term toony and turnout,
you know,
Timothy Leary's ideas was it was legal,
you could actually be in it.
And it was effective.
I mean,
Lsd,
one of my favorite fun facts about Lsd is that it was mostly used,
uh,
initially by psychiatrists to get insights into what it was like to be
psychotic.
It was called a psychotomimetic.
And in other words,
it mimes the effects of psychosis.
So psychiatrists who dealt with psychotic people is,
my wife does,
would take LSD to like,
oh,
this is what it must be like to be them.
This is what it's like to hear voices into lose touch with reality and to have
all this overwhelming input.
And,
and then they would go back to their patients with a greater compassion and
understanding because they were like,
I get it.
I know what you're,
you know,
what you're going through.
That's fascinating.
Which is what a Shaman does,
right?
Like in shamanic practices,
often it's the shaman who takes the drugs in order to change his or her
consciousness to help you with whatever you're dealing with.
I mean,
that's such a beautiful sort of noble,
a approach to healing.
I was,
uh,
driving yesterday and I drove past a short bus and all those little buses where
kids are troubled.
And there was this little boy,
uh,
he looked like he was Indian.
He looked like he was probably about nine or 10 years old and,
uh,
he was staring at his hands and he was like moving his hands around and nodding
and going back and forth.
He was like,
at first I thought it was just playing,
you know,
I thought it was just a kid in a boss who was bored.
And then,
um,
as I was stuck there at the red light and I'm looking in this window and he was
making noises and his face and he was moving his mouth around and he was just
staring at his fingers and I was realizing like,
oh,
this kid's kind of fucked up.
There's something wrong with them.
And then I started thinking,
man,
I was only,
it was only for,
you know,
whatever it takes for a light to change.
I was thinking like,
what,
what does this guy seeing?
Like what is he seeing?
He's obviously not seeing things that normal people see or experiencing it in
the same way that a quote unquote normal person would.
But he was moving his fingers around and staring at it and bouncing back and
forth and like,
what is this kid's trip like?
What does this light for him?
Is it,
does he have some abnormal levels of neurochemicals?
Like what is causing him to have this experience?
Whatever in his circuitry,
like what is it?
But it was,
you know,
it was sad but fascinating at the same time.
I mean,
I don't know what he was suffering from,
but it was clearly something,
well,
my castle does.
Um,
she's really interesting.
She,
she loves psychotics.
That's her favorite population to work with,
which are,
you
know,
psychotics are the people who have lost touch with reality.
So that kid may have been having a psychotic break or,
you know,
who knows what his thing is.
But I,
the first time I went into her office when I first met her,
it was like one flew over the cuckoo's nest.
Right.
You know,
like the,
the double doors,
the locking doors,
the grates over the windows,
high security people just like,
you know,
completely out of it.
And she loves those people cause she says they're honest,
they're completely honest and they don't lie.
And when she meets them,
and I've seen this happen in the street and it countless times at this point,
she laughs,
she just laughs and they,
cause they know they're crazy.
There's part of them that's observing and they know they're acting ridiculous
and they're like shouting at,
you know,
something that they know isn't there but they can't help it.
So she laughs and it's very friendly,
open way and,
and they like,
oh,
like you get it,
there's,
they have this rapport.
It's a really beautiful thing I've never seen happen before,
but it's almost like a shamonic kind of connection she has with people.
But you know,
she,
she sees kids like that and she's just like,
oh,
I love those kids.
I love how she's not afraid of them at all.
She's afraid to normal people because we're all lying,
you know,
she's not good at,
it's a weird thing.
As a psychiatry.
She's not good at seeing through bullshit.
She,
she smells it,
but she,
she just like fleas from it.
So she had was rather have it were bullshit.
It's not even an option.
So even on the towel,
she wants honesty and like if that means you're drooling and pissing down your
leg,
that's fine.
It's just that she doesn't care about that.
Lucky for me,
boy she and outlier.
Yes.
She's,
she's a bit of a nutcase herself,
you know,
in the best possible way.
I mean,
I often think like a,
someone who works in,
you know,
I'm a psychologist,
I spent a lot of time thinking about this stuff.
Somebody works in mental health is like a lifeguard,
you know,
and 99% of us are the lifeguard who stands on the beach.
And if you're in trouble,
they'll like throw you a a ring and wish you luck.
She dives in,
she goes right into the water,
which is really dangerous and very rare.
Um,
and one of the reasons,
honestly,
she's been on a break for a few years because it was blowing her mind there for
a while.
Wow.
So it was good to be able to fuck off to America for,
I would imagine the burden of that would be pretty intense.
When I was a fucking my fucking off my way through college,
I shouldn't say fucking my way through.
I didn't really do much fucking college unfortunately.
But uh,
I got it.
I went to Umass Boston and uh,
I basically was wasting my time there.
I was only really going because I didn't want to be a loser.
I go there cause I would tell people,
oh,
I'm going to Umass Boston,
you know,
wasting my time when I was trying to think of what would be a career that
I would be interested in.
Psychology was the only thing that interest me because I thought,
well at the very least,
at least I kind of understand how to manage my own mind because a,
I obviously had a lot of troubles.
There was a lot going on in there that I was trying to always wrestle with
inside my head and I felt like it,
at least I do,
that I will have a greater understanding of my own problems.
But then I thought about it and I'd be like,
but I will be dealing with other people's fucking problems all the time.
And I just don't have the patience for that.
I admire people who do,
but I'm not one of them.
I just,
I,
there's,
I believe that that shit is contagious.
And I think that negative energy,
laziness,
slovenly behavior,
all that stuff wears on you.
Because I think we imitate our atmosphere far more than we want to admit.
And we become in sync with our atmosphere far more than we care to admit.
And if you're around a lot of really positive,
really healthy people,
you tend to gravitate towards positive,
healthy behavior.
But if you're around people that are constantly self sabotaging,
you'll,
that becomes the standard that becomes the norm.
It's your culture.
It's yes.
And it's not,
it's not good for you.
And it's very,
very frustrating to me when I'm around people that are sabotaging themselves.
I get angry.
I get,
well,
you just fucking stop,
get your fucking shit together.
I,
which is not really a healthy way to approach them because it doesn't work.
You can't yell at someone and say,
get your shit together.
But it's almost like impulsive because I know that it's creeping into my brain.
Like you're spitting on me.
You fuck,
you're sick,
you're sneezing with your mouth over your mouth.
You're,
you're coughing in my face.
And that's what someone's doing when they're filling.
They're,
they're sabotaging their life in front of you consistently and continually and
they drag you into their world.
We'll fucking help me.
Like,
no,
you are a grown person.
Help yourself.
God Damn it and you get sucked into it.
You know,
like you,
okay,
I'm going to call you.
I'll call you later.
Then you have to call and check up on them and they're crying and like,
what the fuck?
You know,
it's like,
like when people don't get their shit together,
it becomes contagious.
And I,
I worry about that when it comes to psychology.
I worry like,
like people that are constantly dealing with other people's disasters and
fuckups if that's your day is just every day you're dealing with someone who
can't stop eating cake or they can't stop jerking off or they can't stop
whatever it is that they're hung up on.
Whatever craziness.
I always feel like men in trying or even making an attempt to help those people,
you're sort of giving up a lot of your sovereignty when it comes to your own
established mental state.
Yeah.
Which is why,
you know,
concealed has got extremely firm boundaries and when we're like,
if we're hanging out with someone,
you know,
potential friends or whatever,
just people,
whatever,
if she detects something that's not
right,
she's just like,
yeah,
I'm going to go home.
And she's out.
Like,
Eh,
she's not gonna she,
cause I think it's what you're describing.
She feels like if this isn't a clinical situation where I'm in charge,
then I feel she feels contaminated.
Whereas I feel more like,
yeah,
whatever.
You know,
Pete,
everybody's got their weird shit.
But then I find myself developing friendships with people and then a year or two
down the road it's like fuck,
you know,
they,
they weird out on me and like I didn't see that coming.
And she'll say,
are you kidding?
I saw that come in the day he met that guy.
Like why?
We just,
you know,
I tried to warn you,
well there's some people that are undeniably toxic and by toxic it doesn't
necessarily even mean that they're trying to harm you.
Right?
They might be toxic just by the fact that they're fucking so self indulgent and,
and they're,
they're,
they're always like,
there's a lot of people that constantly want to talk about their own problems,
like their own problems take precedent over everything that's going on.
And it's just this constant examination of their own faults and they never get
better.
Those Fox,
those fuckers,
they,
they constantly repeat the same problems.
And I think that a lot of them,
they have even addictions and that these addictions,
whether it's alcohol or drugs or whatever the fuck it is,
those addictions they have are almost like,
it's like facilitates this need to talk about themselves and then problems,
they create more problems.
So they're constantly addressing their problems.
Yeah,
I hear that.
And that's why she prefers psychotic.
It's cause they're not doing that.
Make sense?
They're crazy.
They really are just a pain in the ass.
But psychotics,
they can't help it.
They're just like that.
They're born that way.
While to wrap it all up,
Chris Ryan and we fucking doomed.
When is this book coming out,
by the way?
Probably next summer.
Are you almost done with it or is it the editorial process?
Not yet,
but within,
I'd say within a month I'm gonna,
I'll turn it in and then fully
the country and then when you turn it in,
is it a bunch of fucking bean counters start going over your shit and deciding
which way it should go because you have to give up a little bit of creative
controlled in order to have it published.
Right.
Is that how it works?
Yeah.
I mean it depends where you are in that world,
you know?
I mean,
you know,
it's probably the same like with a comic,
right?
It's your first special.
The producers are going to have a lot to say,
is someone like you?
You can walk in and say,
no,
I'm going to do it this way,
take it or leave it.
But even then,
like there was some bits that I like,
comedy central wouldn't put on my last special.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
They were like,
you can't do that one touch this one.
We can't put that one on the air.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'll go love them.
You could do a year in a position with your platform where you could just say,
all right,
comedy central aisle,
you know what,
I'm going to pay tape,
it's myself and a small club in La and then distribute it through my podcast and
cut you guys out.
You could do that.
The earlier regime,
right?
Like
the regime that they have now is really good,
but they had an earlier regime and several years ago I had a conversation with
them over the phone.
We were going over material and in the middle of the conversation went,
stop,
stop.
We're done.
We're not going to do this.
Like they were saying like you've got to do this instead of that,
you can't say that instead of this.
And they were telling me as if like we're gonna create some sit-com together.
Right.
You know like it has I go,
this is like no you did.
That part has to be in,
because it's the whole point.
The whole point about telling the story of Noah and the Ark to an eight year old
retarded boy,
you have to have an 88 year old retired board.
Cause.
So the eight year old retarded boy goes,
well there's a lot of holes and neath doors and they were like,
you can't do that.
I'm just like,
well that's,
it has to be done.
You can't tell me what I can and can't do.
Like that's the whole point.
Right.
Are you saying that eight year old retired boys don't exist or are they just,
you can't ever discuss them?
Which one is it?
Because I'm not making fun of the eight year old retarded boy.
I'm saying the eight year old retired to boys too smart to buy the story of Noah
and the Ark.
Right.
And to them it was just the,
the vehicle was unacceptable.
Like,
well we're done.
We're done here.
Like,
well like,
well why don't you have it like an older brother?
I said that the,
the,
the no,
you're saying this because you want to save your Gig and your Gig is to like be
able to somehow or another justify what you've put on the air to the advertisers
or whoever the fuck is above you.
And like,
you can't do that with comedy.
Like if you may not,
you homogenize comedy,
you just develop.
Unless it's your thing,
like some people like that's how they think,
which is fine,
but they shouldn't be working in comedy.
Well,
he could be like Jim Gaffigan,
he's a hilarious guy,
but his comedy is very like anybody could laugh at it.
Brian Regan,
it's the same thing.
He's Hilarious,
but that is him.
You know,
there's always going to be pop music and some pop music is really fucking good.
And then there's always going to be just a dirty fucking nasty,
like music from the street,
which is also really good.
If that's what you're into.
You turned me on to Doug.
Stan hope,
talking about someone who just goes,
he's fantastic.
Yeah,
he's free.
And he's the opposite of what you're talking about.
Yeah.
He doesn't know.
You can't tell Doug what to do.
It's just,
it's not,
it's never going to happen.
He doesn't care.
He does.
All Doug needs is enough money to get by and he's done,
you know?
I mean,
he lives in this weird fucking town.
Bisbee Arizona,
seven miles from the border of Mexico.
It's this weird artists,
communities get this strangely painted house.
He invites people over his house for Super Bowl party,
like literally the,
the Internet.
He'll like put out a his address and people just come to his house.
He said 500 people over his house for Superbowl parties.
You didn't know.
459 of them.
I mean he's that nuts.
A lot of bean dip.
His girlfriend completely out of her fucking mind,
like legitimately crazy on pills or names.
Bingo.
She shaves her head,
the hair that's left,
she puts blue paint on it and they fucking go out of the house and she's wearing
like socks on her arms.
She's nuts and that's,
that's his,
that's his reality.
He's,
he wears ironic suits and he gets upset because now like more people are wearing
these ironic suits and he's afraid that he's going to get lumped into these
categories of these people that are like trying to act as if they're onic by
wearing,
you know,
ridiculous suits.
He's a,
he's a,
he's a fucking national treasurer.
He really is.
It's so hard for someone to go that road.
So 100% committed that they come out in the other end at Doug's Tahoe most of
the time,
somewhere along the line they sell out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But I mean as far as the public publishing thing,
I'm,
because of the success of sex at dawn,
I'm think I'm in a position to sort of,
you know,
I've got leverage and,
and the guy,
the editor who um,
who acquired the book is the guy who edited sex at dawn.
He works different publisher.
He,
he quit and left.
He's with someone else.
So he's cool and he,
we know,
we've known each other for years and
that's nice when you develop a relationship.
I've heard of authors that have relationships,
they're editors and it's really great.
Yeah.
I had a book deal for awhile and uh,
it didn't go well.
It's the same thing as the comedy central thing.
I wrote some stuff and they were like,
well we want it to be like your stand up.
We want you to write.
Like I wrote stuff like that maxim piece where it's not like stand up.
It's just my thoughts on things and they were like,
we want it to be like a laugh every minute.
I'm like,
th th th the we'd done,
we're done.
So I gave them their money back.
I gave them their advanced back.
My friend Steve Rinella was a writer's like,
do you understand that?
That's like every writer's dream to give the money back and tell him to go fuck
off.
We'll see.
I wouldn't give them money back and tell him to go fuck off.
I think what I'm going to do is eventually decide to sit down and finish it and
just release it online.
I think that might be the best way to do it.
Release it as a an audio.
You're not an audio book,
but a pdf or release it as a book and Ebook.
Yeah,
or maybe find a publisher.
They're just,
well,
you know what I'm doing,
I'm,
I'm a,
and I might be getting a little ahead of myself here,
but I've been talking to a company called misfit.
Very cool guys.
Interesting story.
They're based in Fargo,
uh,
sorta like busy.
One of the,
and the guy was,
he quit his job.
He was working on Wall Street,
um,
J D or I can't remember what his name is,
but he was working on Wall Street,
making a bunch of money late twenties,
get going to marry his high school sweetheart and I'm,
they're going to go to The Bahamas or something on their honeymoon.
And he goes in and he's talking to his boss and his boss says,
oh listen,
by the way,
I'm sorry it congratulations on the wedding this weekend,
but you gotta be in here Monday cause we got this from some deals coming up.
And he's like my honeymoon.
He's like,
man,
uh,
sorry.
You know,
you're,
it's Wall Street.
You're working for the big boys now.
Oh and uh,
we're going to give you a bonus,
you know,
bump up your annual salary now to two 50 instead of the Aad or whatever it was.
Right?
And so he goes back to his office and he's like,
I just got a $75,000 raise,
a,
I'm making a quarter of $1 million on 28 years old and I can't go to The Bahamas
on my honeymoon.
Fuck this.
And he says,
I got to quit.
And,
uh,
it was December 29th and if he had stayed till the end of the year,
he would have had it his end of year bonus,
which was like 50 grand or something.
But he said,
if I stay two more days,
I won't do it.
You know,
it's that moment you're on the edge,
you're either going to jump on or not.
And he went in,
he said,
sorry,
I'm out.
Quit.
Quit his job.
Right.
Ballsy dude,
ballsy dude.
Had no money saved because he was,
you know,
living the high life.
And,
uh,
I was actually in debt and he,
and so they couldn't go to The Bahamas.
They got married and he and his sweetheart got on the train and just went across
America on Amtrak.
And the train stopped in Fargo and he was like,
I love that movie.
Let's,
let's get off and check this place out.
And they ended up spending a few weeks there and fell in love with it.
Wow.
And he started going North Dakota Fargo and he said,
it's a really cool town and there are all these great artists there and really
creative people and it's this cause there's nothing for hundreds of miles.
So like all the interesting people like are in Fargo.
And uh,
he said it's his great town.
So they,
they opened this business where they sort of do like,
um,
the branding for cool company.
So the only work with who they want to work with.
And Anyway,
so I'm talking to them about putting together a book of excerpts of some of the
best episodes of my podcast.
Ah,
that's a great way for people who don't listen to podcasts and for people do
listen to podcasts to give as a gift,
right.
To their dad or their with a girlfriend or whatever you,
I mean,
you guys could put together a fucking encyclopedia.
But anyway,
I mean like,
why not?
You've got all these great interviews with really interesting people,
you know,
why not make an Ebook or a physical book or whatever,
and stuff like that.
Do
you have people are into reading it instead of listening to it?
I mean,
why not?
And,
and you know,
and there's some forms,
some places where listening to it's not appropriate or not,
not an option on the toilet.
Yeah.
I just think there's so many different ways you get information now.
It's such a cool time.
Yeah.
I just,
I'm so between podcasting and blogging and people creating little internet
videos of their own and,
and these,
these youtube content people,
like I had this Guy Louis on yesterday from unbox therapy and he like reviews,
technological things on boxes them and he's very educated on them and it really
explains the ins and the outs and it really educates your,
you're,
you're buying options because it gives you a lot of information that's pretty
unique.
But these guys,
like there was no option like that before.
There was no like in depth consumer reports that completely uncensored without
commercials for 10 15 whatever minutes he chooses to upload the video completely
up to him.
The same thing as we were talking about the impact of the Internet has,
what an amazing thing it is because there's never been something like a podcast
like this.
It's going to,
this podcast is going to reach a million people and it's got,
I mean there's,
this one is going to get downloaded by a million people plus and over the course
of x amount of years,
who knows how many million it'll be because it's always up available.
It's always free.
Anybody can download it and it's available in a bunch of different forms.
So you can get it from youtube,
you can get it from Vimeo,
you can get it from Ustream,
you can get it from a stitcher,
you can get it from iTunes.
You get it as an MP three it's just available on all these different,
so it just keep,
and you can say whatever you want and no one's gonna stop you.
And that,
that never existed before.
There's never been something like that before.
That's why I hope we're not fucked.
I don't know if we're fucked,
but I know that this thing that we have right now is fucked like this set up,
you know,
the,
the Congress and the Senate and the fucking lobbyists and the president and the
diff,
you know,
corporations,
corporations.
The movement has been,
you think about the focus of power,
right?
It's been from a hunter,
gatherers dispersed,
egalitarian hunter gathers.
Then you got despots that came,
you know,
gathered the power in agricultural societies.
Then the despots get together and form institutions,
primarily the church first,
then you've got,
um,
political,
uh,
institutions.
Then you've got corporate,
Insta,
economic institutions.
What's next?
There's gotta be a next,
yeah.
So I'm hoping that the next will be a return to the dispersed power because of
what we're talking about.
Because now we've got direct connections to everyone.
It seems entirely possible.
And it seems,
at least if it's not the only option,
it will be an option.
It'll be like there'll be,
uh,
corporations that are set up that are more ethical and more connected to people
and more grounded in their approach to trying to acquire money as opposed to
like what we've got now.
The infinite growth paradigm,
which is kind of out of control.
It's just,
he can't ha,
it's not sustainable.
It doesn't make any sense,
but yet it's the norm.
Like this nonsustainable idea is the one that everybody pursues as opposed to,
hey,
everybody isn't $1 billion enough a year.
We're good.
Right?
We're good right here.
Let's just,
you know,
I mean it's,
it just seems like these kind of discussions and discussions like this,
whether it's on social media or what have you,
and just people's ability to Google and actually get the raw data and kind of,
it educates understanding and,
and,
and it just changes the way we view it.
Instead of viewing it as,
you know,
this is how it is and that's how you do and you don't wear a card because you
have to,
you do it because that's what you were born to do.
And then this actor smiles,
who by the way is not fucking working hard.
He's an actor and it doesn't even talk.
I mean,
bizarre,
bizarre and ironic.
I mean,
what an easy job when we come in and close.
Mike,
when we get right here,
I want you to smile,
but not a,
not a happy smile.
Like I'm a rugged man with the catalyst hens wearing overalls.
I mean,
I think we're,
we're seeing the bullshit better than we've ever seen it before and that's at
least step one.
That is my hope right there.
Look at you.
You becoming an optimistic coming.
It's like I have grandkids or something.
Not that I know of.
All right.
Let's wrap it up.
You still doing tangentially speaking every week,
every week.
Get it on Itunes,
everywhere.
Your finer podcast sites.
Chris Ryan,
Ph d.
Dot com.
Chris Ryan,
phd on Twitter.
Yup.
That's it.
All right.
Thanks brother.
It's been a pleasure as always.
It's always fun.
Bye everybody.
See you next week because it's like laughing.